Okay, dann muss ich mal kurz ein bisschen lüften hier.
Lüft-Champ.
Das machen wir heute gar nicht.
Heute machen wir das übliche, was wir sonntags morgens immer machen.
Genau, Level Capture Bait.
Oder was in der Richtung?
Kurz in die Business-Mails gucken.
Ach, ist das heute?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es den gibt.
Ich habe von all diesen Sachen keinen Plan.
Irgendwas Christliches, auf jeden Fall.
So, was?
Ah, wie? Kein Mailer, U-Anti-Cheat mehr.
Wahrscheinlich wollte es keiner mehr spielen damit.
Ja, so ungefähr ist das Verhältnis bei uns.
Für eine Minute Video schwätze ich wahrscheinlich eine Viertelstunde.
Kommt noch das Video an.
Okay.
Tja, aber ich werde es wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht ausprobieren.
Mal kurz gucken, wie viele Spiele das hat.
Steamstats.
Naja.
Umgekehrt.
Ungefähr die Hälfte vom Battlefield.
Wirklich sustainable sollte das aber nicht sein.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die mit dieser Spieleanzahl, wenn die nicht super krass reincashen alle,
da irgendwie langfristig was machen.
Naja, mal gucken.
Ja, aber selbst wenn es rauskommt, glaube ich nicht, dass ich das großartig...
Mal gucken, ob es überhaupt jemals aus der Beta rauskommt.
So, ich bin echt noch ein bisschen...
Oh, guck mal, hier gibt es Trends.
Hier wurden gerade Trends angezeigt.
Warum werden die Trends...
Ah, hier.
Schlagt den Star.
Star Sieger.
Who cares?
Italien, Deutschland.
Juckt mich nicht.
Pfingsten Bedeutung.
Irgendwas Christliches.
Iron Man.
Hamburg.
Alles uninteressant.
Das Einzige, was mich interessieren würde, ist immer noch, warum dieser Zug umgekippt ist.
Es ist ja anscheinend noch nichts rausgekommen.
Ich meine, Züge kippen normalerweise nicht einfach um.
Jetzt stellt euch doch mal wirklich vor, ne.
Ihr fahrt nie Zug und ihr kauft euch ein 9-Euro-Ticket und dann seid ihr in einem Zug, der umfällt.
Indem ihr normalerweise nie drinnen gewesen wärt.
Also, das war richtig scheiße, oder?
Stimmt.
Aber soll ich dir mal was sagen?
Ich habe immer montags frei.
Mir bringt das überhaupt nichts.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Feiertage Hessen.
Wie sieht es denn aus?
Wann kommt denn wieder was?
26.
Das ist jetzt Vatertag, ne?
Achso, Moment.
Das ist ja schon vorbei.
Das hier haben wir als nächstes.
16.
Da muss ich Urlaub nehmen.
Unbedingt.
Also, hier.
Da.
17.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Tag der Deutschen Einheit ist auch wieder montags.
Alter, kann das nicht mal...
Hätten wir uns nicht mal irgendwie einen Tag später vereinigen können?
Gatschi-Bass.
Was soll das?
Montag.
Da bringt mir ja gar nichts.
Und danach erst wieder an Weihnachten.
Oh, das liegt ja mega beschissen, Alter.
Boah, liegt Weihnachten dieses Jahr kacke.
Guckt mal.
24. ist Samstag.
Feiertage ist Sonntag und Montag.
Da habe ich ja gar nichts von.
Das ist ja mal hardcore.
Das ist ja mal ultra beschissen, Alter.
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag.
Dann ist Silvester.
Dann ist Silvester wahrscheinlich auch am Sonntag.
Ne, am Samstag.
Alter, das ist ja mal hardcore beschissen.
Ich finde, man sollte das so regeln, dass Weihnachten nie auf Feiertage fallen...
Also, nie auf freie Tage fallen darf.
Warum? Bist du Friseur?
Ne, was hat das mit Friseur zu tun?
Achso, Friseur.
Ja, weil Friseur montags zu haben.
Ne, aber ich bin montags auch nicht auf der Arbeit.
Das heißt, wenn das so ist...
Samstag frei, Sonntag normal frei, Montag normal auch frei.
Das heißt, ich kriege im Prinzip nichts extra durch Weihnachten.
Ja, dann brauche ich Weihnachten auch nicht.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, dass die vor ein paar Monaten diesen...
Die wollten noch so einen Corona...
Einen einmaligen Corona-Feiertag oder irgendwie sowas einführen.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wo sie gesagt haben, die Leute sollen daheim bleiben und sonst wie was?
Da war ich sofort dafür.
Warum ist mir egal.
Daheim bleiben ist gut.
Der 24-26-Jahr soll nie auf...
Ja, der soll nie auf Tage fallen, die normalerweise auch so frei wären.
Das wäre doch am besten.
Im Zweiten muss man halt ein bisschen im Dezember die Tage kürzen und überspringen.
Das ist ja mal so schwer...
So schwer sollte das jetzt ja nicht sein.
Dann lassen wir beispielsweise den...
Den dritten...
Den dritten Dezember weg oder so.
Und dann können wir den 24. Dezember dann am Donnerstag machen und sowas.
Das finde ich gut.
Den Folina-Exploit...
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Also ich glaube, irgendwie super krasse Erkenntnis haben wir dann da auch nicht.
Wir führen im Endeffekt irgendein Python-Skript aus.
Und dann geht der Windows-Calculator auf.
Glaube ich, standardmäßig war es.
Beziehungsweise, nee.
Ja, doch.
Ich glaube, dass es keine solche Regel gibt.
Ach, nee.
Da wäre ich jetzt gar nicht drauf gekommen, dass es so eine Regel nicht gibt.
Aber ich hätte gerne so eine Regel.
Ich meine, wir sind doch mittlerweile so schnell dabei,
bei allem, was einem nicht gefällt, zu sagen, das muss man regeln und verbieten.
Dann können wir doch auch mal sowas regeln und verbieten, oder?
Ich meine, wenn das eigentlich eine sinnvolle Sache ist,
dann lässt man halt mal den ersten oder zweiten Dezember weg.
Man macht quasi einen Reverse.
Ähm, Februar lässt man am Ende was weg.
Im Dezember lässt man einfach am Anfang was weg.
So, dass dann nie auf freie Tage fällt, das Weihnachten.
Dass man zusätzliche freie Tage hat.
Neue LSD-Videos an.
Wir gucken uns die LSD-Videos an.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es da keine Regelung gibt.
Wie gesagt, normalerweise ist es ja auch relativ balanced.
Da hast du schon recht.
Aber trotzdem.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Ich will das über Freiheit an Weihnachten.
Zusätzlich.
Als jemand hatte neuerdings eine Idee, Feiertage am Wochenende nachzuholen.
Die Briten machen das.
Was?
Nee, die machen das nicht, oder?
Ich meine, wenn ein Feiertag in die Woche fällt, dann wird der auch gemacht?
Ach so meinst du das?
Ja, so müsste das sein.
Genau so.
Genau so, Leute.
Wenn es auf ein Wochenende fällt,
dann wird es nachgeholt in der Woche an einem Werktag.
Genau so müsste man das machen.
Aber das wäre wahrscheinlich zu steuerzahlerfreundlich.
Wobei das ja gar nicht mal stimmt.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wo die richtig viele Kohle sitzt.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich lieber, die Leute gehen arbeiten.
Dann könnte man sagen, es wäre zu bürgerfreundlich, wahrscheinlich das so zu machen bei uns.
Ja gut, am Montag, wenn es am Montag nachgeholt wird, bin ich jebaited.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich hätte sonst auch gelitten, weil es am Wochenende ist.
Also es macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Hast du schon das neue Video von Lohnt sich das gesehen vom Programmierer?
Ja.
Habe ich schon.
Haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Der hat einen entspannten Eindruck gemacht.
Er hat gesagt, er verdient mehr Kohle, als er je braucht.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, so muss es sein.
Eigentlich müssten das alle.
Ja, genau.
Der vier Stunden, dieses Popup.
Aber je nachdem, was da alles dranhängt.
Programmiert er ja nicht.
Das habe ich am Anfang auch so als Tastverfahren gesagt.
Aber er programmiert nicht zwangsläufig vier Stunden an dem Hilfe Button, sondern an allen Prozessen und Abläufen drumherum.
Von irgendwelchen Design Dokumenten bis irgendwelche Tester, die es testen müssen und so.
Also kann ich schon verstehen.
Coding with Floats until I go completely insane.
Okay, Floats ist Pains Champ.
Weil, genau, wenn ich das hier schon sehe in der Vorschau.
0.1 plus 0.2 muss nicht 0.3 ergeben.
Das ist so, auch in Floats, aber nur bis zu einer gewissen Precision.
Also sprich, ab einer gewissen Nachkommastelle stimmt es nicht mehr.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn man sagt, okay, in Float 0.9 plus 0.1 gleich gleich 1.
Das ist auch nicht unbedingt so in Floats.
Dafür sind Floats relativ schnell zur Alternative.
Ich meine, die Alternative ist, wenn du was hast, was beispielsweise nicht in ein normales Int reinpasst.
Und du brauchst halt Nachkommastellen.
Was laber ich für ein Schwachsinn?
Wenn du was hast, wo du Nachkommastellen brauchst.
Und...
Da musst du sowas wie BigInt oder sowas nehmen oder irgendwie was in der Richtung.
Was unter der Haube irgendwelche Strings verwendet.
Das ist halt langsam, aber Floats sind halt...
Ich meine, Ints sind schneller, aber Floats sind auch relativ geschwind.
Dafür nimmt man halt in Kauf, dass es Rundungsprobleme und Genauigkeitsprobleme gibt.
Was verdient ein Wirtschaftsprüfer?
Ne, das gucken wir nicht.
Wir gucken uns heute an, was verdient ein Klempner oder sowas.
Wir hatten die glaube ich noch.
Das habe ich schon auf dem...
Lohnt sich Programmierer-Video?
Das habe ich geguckt.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz ein Bonbon lutschen.
Auch das Neue.
Es gibt noch eins.
Es gibt noch ein Neueres.
Ne, den da. Den haben wir schon geguckt.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, wenn man das richtig macht, kann man heute in vielen Handwerkern und Berufen richtig gut leben.
Ich meine, es ist gefragt.
Ich meine, es ist gefragt as fuck.
Und es ist da auch so.
Die suchen händeringend Leute und die müssen dementsprechend, wenn sie die Leute auch haben wollen, das ordentlich bezahlen.
Ich meine, nicht überall wahrscheinlich, so wie immer.
Aber so immer mehr als weniger.
Also immer öfters...
Mach was mit Holz.
Ei, ei, ei.
MonkaS.
Banken arbeiten mit anderen Datentypen.
Ne.
Nicht unbedingt.
Banken haben in der Regel halt ein...
Was ist das?
Decimal ist es in C-Sharp.
Also ein 128-Bit.
128-Bit.
Ein 128-Bit-Datentyp, glaube ich.
Bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, ob es 128-Bit ist.
Ja.
So, was gucken wir uns an?
Also 16 Byte, das sind nur 28-Bit, aber das...
Das reicht in der Regel 28-29 Stellen Genauigkeit.
Gestern war ein Programmierer-Clip auf LSF.
Was ist LSF?
Was, was?
Was, was bin ich hier sehend, Chat?
Was bin ich hier sehend, also...
Hä?
Excuse me?
I literally couldn't finish...
I didn't have enough speed.
I just had the format...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
She baited, oder?
Moment.
Hä?
Das ist doch kein Url-Shortener.
Der returnt einfach den gleichen Kram immer wieder.
Wo ist...
Was ist daran geshortet?
Ach so.
Das ist...
Ja gut.
Du kannst...
Nee, aber wirklich shorter ist es jetzt nicht.
Okay, den...
Den...
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ach, die Tests waren trash.
Ach so.
Okay, das geht jetzt für mich so aus dem Kontext nicht hervor, aber okay, ja.
Ja, das war ja klar, dass der Chat wieder auf das Programming grillt.
Was sonst?
Hätte ich nicht anders erwartet, Chat.
So.
Ähm...
Also, was schauen wir uns heute an?
Zeigt mal her.
Wir lassen uns runter.
Level Capture Bait.
Wenn's dazu...
Was sagt denn mein Ikea-Feinstaubsensor?
Moment, das muss ich kurz checken.
Ist jetzt hier alles in Ordnung drin?
Feinstaubsensor?
Ja.
Ich denke...
Ich denke, dassrite der Mitarbeiter ist um
engineeriert.
sechs Monate verschoben wurde.
Na, das ist aber mal ein...
Also, das kann man sich ja gar nicht behalten, so viel
Geleak ist da. Und
man könnte auch sagen, Battlefield
2042 Season 1 Reveal Date.
Es interessiert noch ungefähr
1500 Leute, wenn überhaupt.
Sekunde, wo wir gerade dabei
sind. New World.
Battlefield.
Okay. Immerhin.
3000 Spieler Peak noch, ja.
Huiuiui, ging's aber ganz schön rauf. Meine Güte.
Also, RIP.
Und New World.
Okay, New World hat's jetzt tatsächlich unter
20k geschafft.
So verkackt man.
Krass, Alter. Ich glaube,
das ist die heftigste
Spieler
Zahlenvernichtung,
die ich je gesehen hab.
Von knapp einer Million
auf 20k.
Bald werden Leaks geleakt.
Oh, guck mal da. McDonald's
Puff Breakfast. Alles klar.
Warum auch immer.
Okay, Levelcap, debate on.
Leaker claims Battlefield 2042
Season 1's Trailer will be revealed very soon.
Modern Worker 2 got a reveal date.
Ein Reveal Trailer
wird bald revealed. Das ist cool.
PlayStation made some massive announcements
and much more on this weekend game.
Okay, Levelcap, schieß los.
Wer sonst?
Battlefield 2042 Season 1 Content Update will be revealed on June 6th
with the media embargo
lifting on June 8th.
Battlefield 2042's first content drop
is expected to launch sometime this month.
Dataminer Temporial has already shared
what he's found in the game files.
Ja, nix. Nix. Eine Map,
ein Specialist und ein paar Kleinkram.
Nix. Absolut lächerlich.
Keck bei Battlefield.
According to him,
the exposure map will be based in a
Canadian mountain range centered around
a secret research facility.
Season 1 will reportedly also introduce
two stealth helicopters
and new weapons. Not to mention the
layout improvements to the kaleidoscope.
Das ist natürlich, was Battlefield 2042
dringend gebraucht hat.
Mehr Helis.
They also made significant changes
to the All Out Warfare playlist.
They replaced the standard 64-player conquest
with what's called Exodus Conquest.
This is an updated playlist featuring
several portal maps mixed in with the
base 2042 maps.
These include Caspian Border and No Shark Canals
from Battlefield 3.
Na, gute Idee, dass man jetzt auch mal die Portal Maps
für was Sinnvolles verwendet.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, wie wäre es mal mit
neuem Portal Content?
Erika Harbour und Vala Pariso
from Bad Company 2.
Ah, das ist gut.
...a short teaser video announcing the reveal date
for Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2.
The teaser featured the members of the
Jetzt mal ernsthaft. Wie kann es ein
reveal date sein, wenn man schon
das revealed hat?
Also, man weiß es ja schon,
dass es das ist. Und
man sieht Ausschnitte daraus. Also wie kann
man ein reveal date
revealen mit was, was schon revealed ist?
Task Force 141 Squad
Ich, ich, ich blicke mittlerweile nicht mehr
durch das.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch, dass es geleakt wird.
Stellt euch mal vor, es wird geleakt,
wann das reveal date revealed wird, mit was,
was eigentlich schon revealed ist.
Dann ist es vorbei. Und dann muss drauf
reacted werden. Und am besten reactet dann
noch eine auf die Reaction. Dann sind wir
komplett...
...alongside this a piece of Call of Duty
artwork was spotted on the Steam Store
page earlier in the week. Valve quickly took it
down, but it got players speculating.
COD titles haven't been released on Steam
since 2018's Black Ops 4. Instead,
Activision has opted solely to publish
the game on its own battle.net service.
However, with the teaser trailer, the
official Steam Twitter page retweeted the
video all the time.
Was der Programmierer aus dem Video hatte,
ein sechs Jahre altes Video von dir in
seinen Favoriten. Tatsächlich, ja? Welcher
davon? Witzig. Und welches Video? Ja gut,
wahrscheinlich irgendein Battlefield oder so.
All but confirming that Modern Warfare 2 will not be released on Steam.
for the place, yes it is.
Bourdeaux Daytime Video
will be coming to steam
by
Massive Space Simulation Games Star
Citizens celebrated its
Invictus Week,
this annual event marks the beginning
of the new Recruiting Year and the
Geraduation of the latest Class of
Officers Engame. It also allowed players to check out the biggest and most iconic ships as Pirates,
vielen anderen Games, die auch
ganz viel Kohle bekommen haben und nichts
damit auf die Reihe bekommen. Die machen ja wenigstens
was. Also man kann nicht sagen, dass
Star Citizen ein Scam-Game ist.
Fertig wird es wahrscheinlich trotzdem nie.
Oder was heißt fertig?
So in dem Zustand, wo man dann
sagen würde, okay, man lässt jetzt die ganze Welt drauf
los.
Moment, die bekommen
immer noch mehr Geld?
Okay, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Warum?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, die Leute haben Vertrauen da drin
verloren, aber anscheinend nicht. Anscheinend sind die
Leute zufrieden mit dem,
was man sieht. Also wie gesagt, ich bin auch der Meinung,
das ist kein Scam in dem Sinn.
Ja, Scams hast du heute
Kickstarter-Scams und sowas hast du ja
in allen Ecken. Ich bin immer noch
etwas
traurig, dass
Camelot Unchained
nix wurde. Ich meine,
ich hab den Kram gebackt
für irgendwie 200 Euro für
Beta-Access und sowas.
In dem Spiel tut sich
gar nix und
die haben letztens, also sie veröffentlichen immer
noch Newsletter, aber es ist komplett lächerlich
und letztens haben die allen
Ärzte, man muss sagen, das Spiel ist auch so irgendwie
sieben Jahre oder so in der Entwicklung
und
die haben letztens
ein Newsletter gepostet,
dass sie jetzt ein neues
Köchersystem implementieren, dass wenn du
eine Bogenklasse
spielst, dass dann, wenn du
den Pfeil verbraucht hast, automatisch
was, wieder einer in den Köcher
kommt. Da hab ich mir gedacht, Moment, was?
Das sind legit
fünf Zeilen Code, darüber schreibt dir ein
Newsletter. Bei einem Spiel, was irgendwie
sieben Jahre Verzögerung hat.
Daran sieht man jetzt alles Bullshit.
Owlcat entwickelt gerade
einen Warhammer-Klassik-RP. Ja, das
interessiert mich. Also ich fand sowohl
Pathfinder, Kingmaker als auch
Wrath of the Righteous ziemlich gut.
Beide haben ein Problem.
Kingmaker und Wrath of the Righteous.
Das letzte Viertel
ist nicht gut.
Also hat ganz
Weirdchamp-Pacing, Weirdchamps
Story, die unfertig wirkt.
Also das letzte Viertel ist nicht gut.
Bei beiden.
Der Rest ist aber richtig
pock.
...
Warhammer 3 Immortal Engines, Blood Bull 3 und Vermintide 2.
Playstation revealed several...
Man kann, man kann es ja auch übertreiben mit Titellängen, oder?
Total War Warhammer 3?
Bla bla bla bla bla.
Das ist ein Titel, da brauchst du ja eine Seite für, um alleine das, das, das, das, da, da, da,
Overflowed wahrscheinlich die Steam-Header-Box.
...
Final Fantasy 16 and a PC-Port of Spider-Man Remastered all made an appearance.
The show itself was a little under an hour long, but being lauded as the best state-of-play
Sony has published so far.
Indie-Titles like RollerDome and Tunic also got Gameplay-
Okay, seriously.
Resident Evil 4 ist glaube ich ein Game, was fast auf noch mehr Plattformen rausgekommen
ist als Skyrim.
Das gab's ja überall, Playstation 2, Wii, Wii U, wahrscheinlich Switch, PC, PS-Dings,
Bums, also meine Güter.
Okay, oder remaken die das, richtig, also remaken die das wie Resident Evil 2 und Resident
Evil 3.
Das wär natürlich, ja, sieht so aus, wenn man sich das im Hintergrund anguckt.
Das ist kein, kein, ähm, wir porten das mal wieder neu.
Ich glaub Resident Evil 4, das Original, gibt's sogar auf dem Handy mittlerweile.
Die machen das im Stile von dem Zweier- und Dreier-Remake, ja, das ist nicht schlecht.
Showcases, not to mention the Callisto Project, a new sci-fi horror developed by the creators
of the original Dead Space Games.
Production of Valve's Steam Deck Docking Station has been delayed indefinitely.
Valve announced this in a news post without sharing how long the dock would take.
Tja, hat jemand von euch eine Ahnung?
Ob Steam Deck Docking Station, oder Steam Deck Docking Station, oder Steam Deck Docking Station
jetzt erfolgreich war, ist, oder nicht?
Ich hab da ja so meine Zweifel, ob das so gut angekommen ist, wie man erhofft hat.
Ist es?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Der Friseur war großer PS Vita-Fan, kann ich mich gar nicht mehr trauern, war er das?
They are reportedly working on improving the situation behind the scenes.
According to them, the issue is caused by shortages in resources and COVID closures
at their manufacturing stations.
Luckily, these shortages won't affect the production of the Steam Deck itself, as separate
teams in different factories make both products.
In 2020, one of the most prominent streamers on Twitch, DrDisRespect, was banned from streaming
on the site.
To this day, it's still unclear exactly why he was banned.
Both parties seem to have moved on from the situation until this week, when DrDisRespect
hosted a $100,000 Fortnite tournament featuring several Twitch streamers.
Rules were issued to each streamer to avoid copyright infringement.
In 2020, one of the most prominent streamers on Twitch, DrDisRespect, was banned from streaming,
to avoid including the doc on Twitch.
They were advised to mute or hide DrDisRespect from their stream and even avoid calling
him by name.
Images or videos featuring DrDisRespect weren't allowed to be shared either.
This is all because Twitch issues bans for people streaming content of previously banned
users.
According to the community forum and news hub Windows Central, Microsoft is working
on an affordable streaming service for their streamers.
Was ist?
Was los, Chet?
Chet, was ist?
Was ist?
Was hab ich verpasst?
War irgendwas im Video?
Achso, wir haben ein Video von ihm.
Oh nein, MonkaS!
Naja, gut, was willst du machen, ne?
Streaming Dongle.
It would be similar to Google's Chromecast, but used to stream and play games via the
Xbox Cloud Gaming Service.
It's codenamed Keystone and is...
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn's danach geht, wenn's danach geht, was du in YouTube Videos so
siehst, das kannst du ja im Vorfeld nicht wissen.
... to release for quite a while.
Some users speculate that the next generation of gaming could focus on game streaming in
this form over the traditional consoles.
2017's Assassin's Creed Origins received a long-desired performance update this week.
Ubisoft released a 60 FPS update for the game on next-gen consoles.
It's been received very well by fans.
Ubisoft previously released a 60 FPS update for the 2018 Assassin's Creed Odyssey last
August, which means all three of the latest releases run at high speeds.
... all three of the latest releases run at high speeds.
dass wir da überhaupt im Jahr 2022 diese Wortkombination noch, ähm, überhaupt haben, ja?
Also.
Was, Chris Klippel? Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Auch unglücklicher Name.
Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen.
Da wusste ich nicht so genau, was ich damit anfangen soll.
Aber ich bin auch kein richtig krasser Sonic-Fan.
Also, ich male keine Sonic-Characters und ich cosplay auch keine Sonic-Characters und ich gucke auch kein Rule 34 Sonic-Characters.
Warum ist eigentlich, ich, ich mache mich ja sonst immer nur lustig über Kokona-Einheiten und, und sowas.
Wisst ihr, was, was richtig blöd ist?
Dass wir 34 sagen und nicht 43 für 34.
Weil warum sagen wir es nicht einfach von links nach rechts?
Ja? 3, 4.
So.
Und warum sagen wir 4, 3, wenn wir eigentlich 3, 4 meinen?
IGN.
Fans immediately saw the inspiration of...
Hold up, Breath of the Wild.
Ja, klar.
Ich muss euch mal ehrlich sagen, ich finde, dass Sonic irgendwie sehr deplatziert in der Welt aussieht, oder?
Das sieht alles halbwegs realistisch aus, hochklassig und dann läuft halt Sonic darum.
Also, wo man halt Beispiel, bei Mario Galaxy sieht man es zum Beispiel richtig gut, dass man auch was gut aussehen lassen kann.
Und, ähm, was aber halt trotzdem Mario-Style aussieht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Figur das zusammenpasst.
Ja, wenn wir 30, 4 sagen würden, wäre gut.
30, 4.
Radio-Signal, danke für den Zapp.
Danke.
gelesen.
Aber wie soll man das...
Ich meine, die Franzosen stehen eh schon unglaublich drauf,
alles einzufranzösischen.
Bisschen wie die Japaner,
die dann englische Wörter nehmen und irgendwie
den U und so hinten dran hängen.
Der Chat hat da bestimmt jede Menge
gute Beispiele für. Mir fällt grad
keins ein, aber ich hab schon öfters gehört,
dass
die nehmen englische Wörter und machen dann irgendwie
so, dass sie japanisch klingen draus.
Naisu,
Naisu zum Beispiel, genau.
Haha, Naisu ist da
das beste Beispiel für.
Oder Christmas. Christmas sagen die
ja auch nicht. Die sagen irgendwie
Christmassu oder so.
Aber gut, so und die
Franzosen sind ja auch richtig
scharf darauf, alles zu Französischen. Aber wie
willst du das durchsetzen im Endeffekt?
And that wraps it up for this week in
Gaming. As always, guys, I hope you enjoyed it.
I hope you enjoyed it and we'll see you next time.
Ich mein, du hast ja genug Teams in CS
beispielsweise, die bestehen jetzt nicht
unbedingt rein aus Franzosen. Gibt's überhaupt noch
ein Team, was nur aus Franzosen besteht?
Hat Fatality noch ein Team? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist ja meistens
gemixt und kannst ja wohl
kaum ein Team machen
mit irgendwie einem Franzosen im
Spanier und zwei Engländer oder so.
Und dann irgendwie müssen die Französisch reden,
wenn die in Frankreich spielen.
Das kannst du knicken.
Fatality sind denen.
Okay, da hätte ich ja nicht gedacht, dass die französischen
Leute gar keine Franzosen haben.
Signing off.
Have something really valuable?
Was? Was ist jetzt?
Da ist eine Wurst.
Eine Wurst.
Also ich muss mal sagen,
das ist aber ein ziemlich gut gemachter
Hotdog, ja. Double Hotdog
ist es sogar. Da sieht
tatsächlich sehr
Hotdoggy aus.
Realistischer Hotdog.
Das ist wie bei uns.
Bei uns hat doch auch mal jemand erzählt
in so einem Interview. Ich bin auch Gamer.
War das nicht? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das war dieser Stream mit Philipp Amthor,
wo sie so getan haben. Wir sind auch krasse
Gamer und hatten keinen Plan, wovon sie reden.
Ja, ja.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel. Da war was.
French President
of Playstrike Mania. Okay.
Naja, viel passiert ja nicht.
Außer, dass das nicht kann.
Naja. Warum nicht?
Das war irgendwie, das war wahrscheinlich
auf irgendeiner Convention oder so, wo er
zeigen wollte, wie
am Puls der Zeit ist.
Ja, jetzt. Ja, cringe.
Von dem hört man in letzter Zeit auch weniger.
So, also, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Mache YouTube
nochmal die Chance, geben wir uns was Gutes vorzuschlagen.
Never do this.
Ne, das macht, das never doen
wir auch, weil
wir spielen kein, äh, was?
Wir programmieren keinen Flutter und kein
äh, Dings.
Äh, wie heißt's?
Dart.
Okay, Julien Bam Video müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Warum kriegen wir das überhaupt vorgeschlagen?
Ich meine, als würde ich normalerweise
mich dafür
sowas in der Richtung interessieren.
Bester deutscher Gamer.
Ähm, anscheinend gibt's
keine gescheiten, keine gescheiten
Vorschläge. Okay,
auf geht's. Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Zeig mal her.
Wer, das, das hat der, das hat
gestern oder so der Chat vorgeschlagen.
Wer jagt die Hacker?
Alina wird Cybercop.
Pains Champ, ja, ne?
Ne, das gucken wir nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt an, wie Alina Cybercop wird.
Erstmal müssen wir mal gucken.
Äh, ist, wahrscheinlich ist das
Alina. Das ist doch absichtlich,
dass es ein bisschen anfängt wie Mission Impossible, oder?
Vielleicht skippen wir auch ein paar Sachen.
Mein 30 Minuten ist schon ganz schön lang.
Nicht so wirklich ein Plan B.
Deswegen muss es einfach klappen.
Heute beginnt das Jahr, das Alinas Leben
verändert. Aha.
Als Polizistin.
Gerade meine Mutter war natürlich so ein bisschen ängstlich,
weil sie gesagt hat... Ah, Schwabe sind's.
...Eig. Man trägt ne Waffe.
Ja, kann natürlich schon auch mal
brenzlig werden. Ey, Moment.
Wahrscheinlich wird's eher brenzlig, wenn du die brauchst
und hast sie nicht dabei.
Unbekannte haben
das Computernetz des Bundestages
attackiert. Hacker hätten versucht,
in die IT-Systeme einzugehen.
Jahrelang von chinesischen Hacker...
...massenweise sensible Daten gestohlen.
...in den Backups sind alle Daten weg.
Kundendaten, äh, die Maschinen können nicht mehr arbeiten.
Das heißt eigentlich ne Vernichtung der Existenz.
Cybercops.
Sie kämpfen für unsere Sicherheit
im Netz. Auch bei den
aktuellen Konflikten in der Welt.
Und Alina...
Natürlich ist ganz wichtig, dass man da ne Pistole
hat, wenn man im Internet
unterwegs ist. Logisch.
Also, der Zusammenhang sollte ja
obvious sein.
By the way, unsere Sicherheit ist zum Beispiel
auch sowas wie, ähm,
äh, die, die RedTube-Daten,
Abmahnwelle, die es damals gegeben hat, oder
super, super Bild, gerade.
Oder, ähm,
irgendwelche anderen Einschränkungen,
dass du nicht mal verschlüsselt kommunizieren darfst
und sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Der Reiz davon, dass man wirklich sagt, man macht ein Stück weit die Welt
ein kleines bisschen besser.
Ja gut, das muss man sich wahrscheinlich einreden.
...doch im Kampf
gegen die Hacker braucht die Polizei
ihr IT-Wissen.
Die analogen Zeiten sind vorbei und du hast immer mehr digitale
Spuren. Es gibt Mordverfahren, die
hauptsächlich digital gelöst werden.
Ja, aber deswegen braucht, ja, deswegen braucht doch
eigentlich derjenige, der,
warum brauchst du da eine Pistole?
Also,
wenn man irgendwie, was weiß ich,
äh, wie nennt man das, äh, Forensiker
oder sowas in der Richtung ist, oder,
ja, was auch immer man, also die Stellen dort,
die halt wirklich dafür sorgen und sich mit
IT auskennen, die brauchen doch keine Pistole,
oder? Egal, gucken wir uns jetzt an,
was das, was das gibt.
Bam.
Direkt.
Grundausbildung, ja,
aber warum muss denn jemand, der
Computerzeug analysieren soll,
eine Polizeigrundausbildung mit Waffe
machen? Ich mein,
äh, wenn man keine Leute haben
will, ist auch okay, ja.
Herzlich willkommen. Dankeschön.
Sie haben heute den ersten Arbeitstag, oder? Genau,
ja. Der erste Tag für Alina
beim Landeskriminalamt.
Hast du nicht Matrix geschaut?
Doch, wir sind uns ja alle einig, Matrix
ist natürlich die realistischste,
realistischste Darstellung von Hacker aller Zeiten.
Die IT-Studentin muss...
Wird nur noch, wird nur noch getoppt durch diesen
uralt Film mit Angelina Jolie hier.
Wie hieß das? Hackers, ähm,
dieser, dieser,
Hacker-Kultfilm, den alle irgendwie geil finden,
wo ich mich damals aber gefragt hab, warum?
Ähm,
ja, das ist,
das ist auch so ein Ding.
Nur zwölf Monaten all das
lernen, was normalerweise...
Es gibt ernsthaft was bei der Bundeswehr, was sich IT-Soldat
nennt. Okay, allein schon,
weil man da eine Grundausbildung machen muss,
werden sie wahrscheinlich keine guten Leute kriegen.
Oder weniger.
Okay, auf geht's.
Nur wenn sie alles schafft, darf sie Kommissarin
werden und Cybercop im
LKA Baden-Württemberg.
Ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Im Staatsdienst. Und das bedeutet
viel Verantwortung.
Das soll ich sich jetzt alles durchlesen.
Hier haben sie mal 50 Seiten
Dokumente, alles durchlesen und unterschreiben.
Und pass auf, das ist der G-Bait.
Das ist der G-Bait.
Wenn sie jetzt unterschreibt, sagt sie ihm
durchgefallen.
Äh, sagt sie ihr durchgefallen.
Das ist bestimmt cheap, cheap. Nein, ist es nicht.
Aber das wär's jetzt.
Aufgrund dieser Belehrung
erkläre ich hiermit ausdrücklich,
dass ich bereit bin, mich jederzeit
durch mein gesamtes Verhalten zu der
freiheitlichen, demokratischen Grundordnung
im Sinne des Grundgesetzes zu bekennen
und für deren Erhaltung...
Ah, jetzt muss der erstmal schwören.
Jetzt muss der erstmal schwören.
Und dann wünsche ich Ihnen alles, alles Gute.
Herzlich willkommen im LKA und...
Den Eid ablegen, ja.
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei den
Pfadfindern, wo man dann, wenn man so ein neues
Halsband bekommt, auch irgendwas schwören muss.
Ich hoffe, dass was danach kommt.
Dass es jetzt mal losgeht mit der
Nur verbindlicher. Hier hast du mehr
Probleme, wenn du dich nicht dran hältst.
Die Ausbildung beginnt für Alina an den Hochschulen für Polizei
in Laar und hier...
Da musst du schwören.
Heute kommen wahrscheinlich viele,
die nehmen das Ding und unterschreiben das nach Wallach.
Hier in Böblingen.
Wir sind beim Jogi.
Jetzt würde ich einfach gern mal in die Runde gehen.
Wo kommt ihr her?
Was habt ihr für eine Vorbildung?
Alina, ich bin 25 Jahre alt.
Ich habe IT-Sicherheit studiert.
Ich bin der David, ich bin 29 Jahre alt,
habe Informatik studiert,
dreieinhalb Jahre als Software-Entwickler gearbeitet.
Ich bin Laura, ich bin 26, komme aus Stuttgart,
habe Wirtschaftsinformatik studiert,
komme aus der Wirtschaft auch.
19.
Wirtschaftsinformatik.
In Alinas Klasse.
Pain's Champ.
Die IT-Welt ist zu komplex.
Die IT-Welt ist zu komplex. Die IT-Welt ist zu komplex.
Es ist komplex, das die Polizei selbst
kein Informatik-Studium anbieten kann.
Sie braucht deshalb Experten von außen.
Naja, die könnten das bestimmt.
Du brauchst halt die passenden Leute dafür.
Wichtigeren Bereich Cybercrime.
Nee, der Babbel, der redet nicht hessisch.
Das ist einordnig schwäbisch, was wieder Dialekt ist.
...haben sich die Spezialisten mit Computern und Zahlen beschäftigt.
Im Seminar gehts um Grundlagen der Polizeiarbeit.
Die größte Herausforderung...
Was? Wer will wem an die Wäsche...
...das man sich...
das Polizeidenken einfach reindenkt.
Weil die eine Sache ist natürlich
das IT und das
muss man jetzt halt ein Stück weit, man darf es nicht ganz
vergessen, aber man muss jetzt einfach zusätzlich
nochmal dieses Ermittlerdenken einfach
in den Kopf reinkriegen.
Und das finde ich schon schwierig, weil das
macht man halt nicht von heute auf morgen.
Ja, klingt logisch. Ja, Polizei ist ein Erfahrungsberuf,
das wird mit der Zeit kommen, aber das
ist irgendwann mal wieder schon ziemlich schwierig,
weil ich mir überlege, hm, okay, wenn ich jetzt
mal überlege... Ich bin mal gespannt,
wie viel Hacker
und Sachen in dieser Richtung überhaupt
in diesem Beitrag vorkommen.
Polizist darf ja leicht vorgehen und
das, ja,
ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Alles, was Alina hier lernt, wird
später in Prüfungen abgefragt.
Fällt sie durch diese Prüfungen,
dann wird es nichts mit der Stelle
als Kommissarin.
Und jetzt schaut
ihr mal mit bloßem Auge
da drauf und ihr seht eigentlich
normale Bekleidung.
Da ist nichts Auffälliges.
Und jetzt setzt ihr da mal die...
Oh, jetzt, hier jetzt kommen die richtigen
Hacker-Mann-Sachen. Jetzt kommt UV-Licht.
Oder sowas.
Kommt her, leuchtet mal drauf
und jetzt seht ihr mal,
was wir jetzt sehen können
auf einmal. Gerade jetzt hier,
das ist jetzt
diese Faser, wo ich euch erklärt habe
von diesem Mord
in Ludwigsburg. Die fluoreszierende
Faser. Ihr habt ja vorher das schwarze
T-Shirt gesehen. Da hat man außer das
hat man eigentlich gar nichts gesehen.
Auch als Cybercop
muss Alina später mit zum Tatort.
Warum?
Dafür.
Warum muss die mit zum
Tatort? Okay, ich meine, vielleicht
Computer analysieren, die da mitgenommen wurden, aber
hä? Okay, dann ist das was anderes,
als ich mir das ursprünglich vorgestellt habe.
Weil was will ich
am Tatort?
Werden die Sinne geschärft.
Okay, kann ja sein. Wer weiß,
was da dahinter steckt?
Na gut, auf der anderen Seite,
wenn ich mir so recht überlege, mein klar,
du brauchst ja auch schon ein bisschen Leute, die Ahnung
von der Technik haben, aber vor Ort auch sich
das angucken.
Ja, genau.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, wenn der PC läuft,
dass du den Computer halt
nicht einfach ausschaltest und im Zweifelsfall
das Ding dann verschlüsselt ist und sowas. Okay, verstehe ich.
Ja, das ergibt
Sinn. Oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, gucken
Datenträger und sonst was.
Okay, das verstehe ich
und unter diesem
Gesichtspunkt macht es natürlich auch Sinn,
dass du eine Grundausbildung machen
musst, weil vielleicht sitzt ja noch irgendein Typ
im Schrank.
Ja, ich stelle dir vor, ihr guckt euch dann
die Wohnung an, du läufst rum.
Was können wir mitnehmen oder was auch immer
und irgendein Typ sitzt noch im Schrank oder so.
Also, gibt es bestimmt
andere Situationen, aber dann verstehe
ich auch, dass sie eine Grundausbildung machen müssen.
Nein, da gibt das schon Sinn.
Mal drauf, weil sie hier
Fasern mitgenommen hat und du auch, nur dass du hier drin warst.
Haben die eigentlich Arzt, Linux?
Linux bei der Polizei?
Ansonsten kann ich ja eh nicht ernst nehmen.
Das wisst ihr, warum es so wichtig ist,
dass wir einen weißen Anzug anhaben,
Mundschutz tragen und und und.
Das richtige Verhalten an einem Tatort wird Alina schon sehr bald benötigen.
Schau das an, siehst du nix?
Siehst du nix?
Punkt eins ist Handschuhe anziehen,
dass man keine Spuren quasi setzt.
Oh, die Schwaben, Alter!
Ich habe früher viel mit Schwaben zusammenarbeiten müssen, das hat sich bei mir eingebrannt.
Der Umgang mit der Asservate, wenn ihr sowas in die Finger kriegt,
dass ihr es gleich verpackt, dass ihr geschützt seid, dass ihr nichts kaputt macht,
dass wir im Labor nachher diese Spuren sichtbar machen können,
dass da nichts verrutscht, weil das ist wirklich der objektive Beweis.
Hechter Akzent.
Ja, wie der Jogi ja gesagt hat, man hat es davor überhaupt nicht im Kopf,
dass man da echt aufpassen muss, gerade auch jetzt hier mit den Spuren,
die jetzt schon an meiner Hose dran sind, von dem, dass man nur in dem Raum stand,
dass man halt Handschuhe anzieht, dass man nicht überall irgendwelche Spuren setzt.
Dass man die Spuren hinterlässt, damit man es halt in Zweifelsfall dann tatsächlich
dem Täter zuordnen kann und dann nicht ewig nach jemandem sucht
und nachher war man es dann tatsächlich selber irgendwie.
Also das war auf jeden Fall mal interessant, das jetzt auch wirklich am eigenen Beispiel,
gerade an meiner Hose zum Beispiel, zu sehen.
Zu Alinas Ausbildung gehört neben der Theorie auch die Praxis.
Zum Beispiel das Schießtraining.
Pepega Aim, mal gucken.
Auch als Cybercop wird Alina später bei Hausdurchsuchungen dabei sein
und muss sich schützen können.
Auf geht's.
Erstmal die gute MP7 rausgeholt.
Falls das eine MP7 ist. Sieht aus wie eine MP7, oder?
Chat.
MP7.
Die Sexy Quickscope erstmal am Schießstand, genau.
Ich stell euch das mal vor.
Da kommt irgendein Typ rein, der wird instant rausgeschmissen.
Ich stell euch mal vor, da dreht sich einer im Kreis am Schießstand.
Das darfst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Du musst wahrscheinlich genau gucken, wo du hin zielst.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, da geht einfach einer rein und macht die Sexy Quickscope,
dann ist es vorbei, der fliegt direkt raus.
Das ist keiner.
Also das ist, glaube ich, klar.
Aber im Zweifelsfall, wenn es halt darum geht, dass irgendjemand anders in Gefahr ist
oder vielleicht auch ich selber, wenn jemand mich bedroht,
das ist halt im Endeffekt das letzte Mittel.
Und ich möchte halt am Ende auch wieder heim nach Hause kommen.
Man kann natürlich wirklich Leute mit verletzen oder sogar umbringen im Zweifelsfall.
Ja, kann man. Dafür ist das eigentlich gebaut.
Ja, man hat immer so Respekt davor, auf jeden Fall.
Also gut, wir werden heute eine ZST-Stunde machen.
Hauptaugenmerk ist ein bisschen Vorbereitung.
Siehste? Hätte das jetzt gestimmt, was die ganzen Killerspielleute früher erzählt haben,
dass man mit Killerspielen quasi übt für Real-Life-Gewalt,
dann hätte die einfach nur genug Killerspiele spielen müssen und hätte das easy geschafft.
Aber wer hätte das gedacht? Es ist nicht so.
Bereitung auf die Kontrollübung, die man...
Es gab ja Leute, die haben wirklich behauptet, dass man mit Spielen schießen lernt und sowas.
...schießen muss.
Da würdet ihr jetzt die einzelnen Sequenzen einfach schießen.
Wir fangen mit der Pistole an.
Aber man sieht, das ist was, was man üben muss. Wer hätte das gedacht, ja?
Ja, das ist was.
Also gut, okay.
Dann...
Dankeschön.
...und zwei Magazine da drauf hoffen.
Ja.
Natürlich müssen sie sehr, sehr konzentriert sein bei dem ganzen Training.
Aufmerksam sein, hohe Disziplin, Selbstdisziplin haben und einfach die Konzentration ist A und O.
Die Pistole.
Denk dran, wenn du an die Waffe hinfährst...
Alina muss Ziele in einer festen Reihenfolge treffen.
Leute, die im Simulator fliegen können, können auch im Real Life fliegen.
Das ist näher dran als Leute, die...
Also tatsächlich, ja.
Das ist aber auch deutlich näher dran an dem, was du im Real Life machst.
Wenn du ein Simulator-Cockpit hast, in einem richtig, richtig guten Simulator, dann ist das ziemlich nah an der Realität dran.
Wohingegen du spielst...
Du zielst mit der Maus in CS GO das, was komplett anderes ist, wie du zielst in echt.
Mit der Pistole.
Also ganz ehrlich, mal angenommen, mal angenommen, ich wäre in einem Flieger und beide oder alle drei Piloten sind arbeitsunfähig, ja.
Und irgendeiner muss das Ding landen.
Ich würde es auf jeden Fall mein Leben lieber in die Hände eines Simulations-Pros legen, als irgendwelche random Leute, wie in Filmen, die dann erzählt bekommen über Funk.
Ja, drücken Sie jetzt den linken, den Knopf oben links.
Weil der Simulationstyp, der weiß wenigstens, welcher Knopf was macht und weiß in der Theorie, wie er das Ding fliegt, beziehungsweise was er machen muss.
Und du kannst ja die meisten Flieger heutzutage automatisch landen.
Also die haben ja fast alle irgendwelche Landeassistenten.
Und der Simulationstyp muss ja dann im Prinzip über Funk dem erklären, wie das einschaltet vielleicht.
Aber der blickt halt viel besser durch, weil er sich im Cockpit auskennt.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall dem Simula...
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, könnte ein...
Call of Duty Pro Quickscope Sniper, was in Real Life easy snipen, versus könnte ein Simulator-Pilot das Flugzeug landen, da würde ich auf jeden Fall auf den Simulator-Pilot tippen.
Und nicht auf den krassen Call of Duty Quickscope Sniper.
Es gibt, ja das stimmt, das stimmt, habe ich auch gelesen, ja.
Zauber reinstechen.
Ob du da bist, wo du hin willst und dann abdrücken, das Ziel wechseln, überprüfen, wieder abdrücken.
Okay?
Ich dachte, mit Pistolen schießt man, oder?
Also immer eins, zwei, immer Holster, oder?
Wo wir da, wo wir da gestochen.
Gucken, wo sie getroffen haben, ich gebe dir das Ziel wieder frei und dann geh ich wieder vor.
Oder die Scheibe.
Okay?
Ja.
Bist du bereit?
Dann Übung frei.
Und genau so nochmal.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich will es jetzt nicht, ich will es nicht, aber ich glaube, auf die Entfernung kriege ich das auch hin.
Gleich nochmal.
Zumindest mit ein bisschen Übung.
Weil das sind, was, fünf Meter oder so?
Noch nicht mal, das sind noch nicht mal fünf Meter.
Und gleich nochmal.
Oder, was sind das?
Zweieinhalb Meter?
Aber gut, ich meine, man muss ja, drei Meter, okay, ich meine, man muss ja, man muss ja klein anfangen letztendlich.
Man kann die jetzt nicht irgendwie da hinten hinstellen.
Und sagen, hier, mach mal.
Der erste Schuss war sehr zügig.
Da ein bisschen mehr Zeit lassen.
Beim letzten, der übliche letzte Schuss, nochmal die Konzentration hochhalten.
Passt aber sehr schön auch mit dem Trigger Reset.
Alles klar.
Bereit?
Ja.
Übung frei.
Jetzt konzentrieren, nicht zu hastig ziehen, was wir vorher besprochen haben.
Und von daher müsste es passen, okay?
Ja, man muss natürlich die ganzen Schritte in der richtigen Reihenfolge machen.
Weil gerade jetzt einmal vergisst, die Waffe zu erheben.
Das muss man sich so entsichern.
Dann schießt er halt nicht.
Das sind halt so Sachen.
Jawoll, ich will den MP7-Typ sehen da hinten.
Gib ihm.
Dann trifft man halt auch nicht.
Man muss sich halt wirklich konzentrieren, dass man wirklich im Ziel bleibt.
Weil man schießt halt auch relativ schnell mal daneben, wenn man sich nicht konzentriert.
Man hat es ruhig.
Der erste Schuss war manchmal ein bisschen zu zügig.
Und dann, ja, ist halt schwierig mit dem Treppen.
Nicht auszudenken, wenn Alina im Ernstfall nicht jeden Handgriff beherrschen würde.
Jetzt mal realistisch betrachtet, das ist ja auch was, wo sie in der Militärausbildung große Probleme haben.
Der Ernstfall, also du kannst nicht wirklich wissen, wie jemand im Ernstfall reagiert.
Du kannst das zwar alles trainieren und deswegen trillen die das ja auch den Leuten rein, dass die quasi unter Druck dann quasi nur noch aus dem FF das abspulen müssen.
Aber du wirst auf jeden Fall, ganz im Ernst.
Sobald dir das erste Ding entgegenfliegt, wirst du wahrscheinlich andere Probleme haben, als der jetzt auf dem Schieß stand, ja.
Aber es ist natürlich wichtig, dass du die Basics so weit, wie wir es auf YouTube wissen, ja, die Basics sind wichtig.
Dass du viele Sachen automatisch machst.
Aber ich glaube, das ist in echt immer was anderes.
Da kannst du dir noch so viel im Vorfeld überlegen.
Ja.
Übrigens, da habe ich ein interessantes Video zu gesehen, warum man mittlerweile, also wer damit angefangen hat, dass man auf Ziele schießt.
Also sprich, oder nein, nicht, dass man auf Ziele schießt.
Wer damit angefangen hat, dass man mit echt aussehenden Zielen trainiert, ja.
Und das war wohl zu Zeiten von, keine Ahnung, ich versuche das aus dem Video wiederzugeben, was ich da gehört habe.
Das war wohl aus den Zeiten von Napoleon rum.
Und da haben die festgestellt, dass die Leute in der Schlacht absichtlich vorbeischießen.
Die standen halt voreinander, kamen teilweise noch aus dem gleichen Dorf oder sonst was und sollten dann aufeinander schießen.
Und da haben halt viele Leute vorbeigeschossen.
Also die hatten eine mega schlechte Trefferquote, eine mega schlechte Effizienz.
Die haben absichtlich vorbeigeschossen, haben nicht richtig getroffen, die wollten sich gar nicht erschießen.
Und daraufhin hat man angefangen zu trainieren.
Mit Zielen, die quasi aussehen, ähnlich dem, was man als Feinde erwartet.
Also menschlich aussehende Ziele angefangen zu trainieren.
So nach dem Motto, irgendwelche Heu-Dinger genommen und da was drüber gemacht.
So nach dem Motto, dass die Leute halt hinrennen und ihr Bajonett reinrammen und drauf schießen.
Also sprich, dass die sich überhaupt keine Gedanken mehr drüber machen.
So nach dem Motto, hey, das ist der Karl von nebenan, den ich jetzt erschieße.
Sondern einfach in your face.
Ja.
Also da kommt das wohl her.
Weil die zu Napoleons Zeiten so krass ineffizient waren, dass sie gesagt haben, nee, da müssen wir was am Training ändern.
Ja Moment, ich rede jetzt nicht von der Polizei.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Bei der Polizei solltest du nicht random einfach einem dein Bajonett reinrammen, falls du eins hast.
Das ist vielleicht eine blöde Idee.
Ich mein, gerade, ihr müsst euch das ja mal angucken, gerade in Deutschland ist es ja so, wenn da einer erschossen wird.
Das ist ja immer riesen Diskussion.
Du hast ja teilweise Diskussionen, so nach dem Motto, es gab doch letztens vor einem halben Jahr oder so dieses eine Video, wo da, wo irgend so ein verwirrter Typ mit dem Messer auf die Polizei losgerannt ist und die Polizei haben ihn dann erschossen.
Und beziehungsweise die Polizei haben ihn noch versucht nicht zu erschießen, haben ihn halt ungünstig getroffen.
Danach gab es doch einen riesen Aufschrei, so nach dem Motto, warum habt ihr den erschossen?
Ich mein, hallo, der Typ steht da, hat ein Messer in der Hand, rennt auf die Polizei zu mit dem Messer.
Was sollen die denn machen?
Also wenn du wirklich so blöde bist und auf die Polizei mit dem Messer zu rennst, also ich, dann, da musst du dann mit rechnen, dass du das nicht überlebst.
Das ist genau so, ähm, wie diesen einen Typ, den sie mit der Axt, mit der Axt im Zug erschossen haben.
Wo ich mir so denke, also wenn du mit der, mit der Axt in den Zug gehst und da Leute bedrohst oder sogar Leute anhackst mit der Axt.
Da musst du halt damit rechnen, dass du den Scheiß hast.
Da musst du halt damit rechnen, dass du den Scheiß nicht überlebst.
Also entweder killt dich einer im Zug von den Leuten, der da drin ist oder, ich mein, in gewisser Weise muss einem doch klar sein, wenn man manche Sachen macht, kann das schlecht für einen ausgehen.
Ich darf mal geschwind, äh, Probe.
Natürlich, ja, mach einen Probeanschlag.
Ich glaub, das ist, ich glaube, bissle too much.
Ja, dann, fahr ein bissle ein.
Bissle einfahren.
Hier oben, nach oben ziehen, mein Mensch.
Okay.
Dann guckst du, ob alles passt, die Zieleinrichtung passt.
Waffe geladen.
Dann gezielte Schüsse, egal, keine Deutschschüsse jetzt.
Und dann Übung frei.
Wie nicht? Full Auto.
Einfach Recoil-Pattern lernen und nach unten ziehen. Easy.
Sauber dran lassen, ja.
Hast du schon mal geschossen? Ja, nur das, was jeder schon mal gemacht hat. Nix, äh, ich war noch nie irgendwie auf dem Schießstand und hab da mit echten Sachen geschossen.
Ja.
Normalerweise haben Polizeianwärter drei Jahre Ausbildung.
Recoil-Pattern lernen, Full Auto, nach unten ziehen. Nach unten, nach unten links.
Alina muss alle Handgriffe im Schnelldurchgang in nur einem Jahr drauf haben.
Ja, gut. Die, die legen da bei ihr aber bestimmt auch andere Maßstäbe an, als bei einem, der quasi für den, ich sag mal, Fronteinsatz drei Jahre ausgebildet wird.
Bei ihr ist es wahrscheinlich okay, die muss wissen, wie das Ding funktioniert, also wie du das entlädst, wie du es nachlädst, wie du es benutzt.
Aber die erwarten da von der bestimmt nicht, dass die jetzt irgendwelche Trainingskurs-Dinger, äh, besteht oder sowas in, in, äh, ja, größerem Ausmaß.
Ich denk mal, da werden schon andere Maßstäbe angelegt für einer, der Cybercop wird, versus einer, der quasi normale Polizist über drei Jahre wird.
Also das, ich geh mal schon davon aus, dass es da unterschiedliche Sachen gibt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie exakt das gleiche erwarten, weil warum sollten sie da nur ein Jahr, äh, die Ausbildung machen, das wär ja bescheuert, ja.
Pff.
Pistole und Maschinen...
Alter, kein ACOG-Visier, cringe, äh.
Aber eigentlich muss man mir ehrlich sagen, Iron Sight, Master Race.
Also allein schon, dass da mit Scope gespielt wird.
Pistole gehören zum Standard-Repertoire der Polizei im Einsatz.
Kein Iron Sight-Enjoyer, Alina.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Wo, wo ist der Hacker-Part? Ist eine gute Frage, wo ist der Hacker-Part? Das denk ich zu einem Drittel um, es kam noch nix dazu, ja.
Bin zufrieden, die Konzentration war oben.
Hat man, denk ich mal, auch ganz gut an den Treffer-Ergebnissen gesehen.
Von daher war's ein erfolgreiches Training.
Beim Schießtraining ist auch Kommissar Fabian Herrmann dabei.
Ach, Moment, das ist...
Von daher war's...
Ist das jetzt ne echte Waffe? Oder ist das eine Simulationswaffe?
Oder ist das was, wo man aufgenommen sieht mit irgendwelchen Platzpatronen, nee, nicht Platzpatronen, mit irgendwelchen Markern, wo das hingeht?
Also irgendwelche Farbpatronen oder wie funktioniert das?
Erfolgreiches Training.
Beim Schießtraining ist auch Kommissar Fabian Herrmann dabei.
Er hat die gleiche Ausbildung wie Alina vor sieben Jahren absolviert.
Und erlebt, als Quereinsteiger hat man es bei der Polizei nicht immer leicht.
Also ich bin ja noch einer, der zweite Jahrgang überhaupt, da war das für viele ganz unvorstellbar, dass da einer kommt, der gerade erst die Ausbildung gemacht hat und dann lässt man den mit Waffe auf die Straße laufen und so.
Aber inzwischen legt sich das.
Also durch die Erfahrung und nach einer...
Also ich bin jetzt seit sieben Jahren mal dabei und dann ist man kein Unterschied mehr.
Da wird nicht mehr unterschieden, weil da ist man vollwertiger Polizist, wie für alle anderen auch.
Auf dem Weg zur Polizistin hat Alina auch Stationen beim Kommissariat, zum Beispiel beim Kriminaldauerdienst.
Hier wird sie mit harten Fällen konfrontiert.
Auch das muss sie packen.
Aber bisschen wenig Cyberfokus ist bis jetzt schon, oder?
Hallo.
Eine Frau mit ihrer Tochter aufgelaufen und zwar ist die wohl Opfer von einer Sexualstraftat geworden.
Und das muss aber schon über sich ein ganz längerer Zeitraum gestrickt haben. Die Frau ist ziemlich aufgelöst und die Tochter auch.
Also ich habe jetzt so die Hälfte verstanden von dem, was er gesagt hat.
Und von daher wäre es ganz gut, wenn ihr euch das mal anhören könntet.
Und natürlich idealerweise von einer Frau oder einer Kollegin, die sich das mal anhört.
Okay, ich würde da schon Yvonne rufen, weil die ist da sehr erfahren in den Dingen.
Und die...
Der Typ sieht aus wie ein etwas dickerer Captain Price.
Guckt euch mal den vom Gesicht an.
Frau oder Kollegin, die sich das mal anhört.
Der Typ sieht übelst aus wie Captain Price.
Guckt mal, bloß ein bisschen dicker.
Einmal von der Nase, von den Augen, vom ganzen Gesicht her.
Das ist ein schwäbischer Captain-Priester-Typ.
Okay, ich würde da schon Yvonne rufen, weil die ist da sehr erfahren in den Dingen.
Und die geht dann mit ihr runter und...
Und soll gleich mitgehen.
Okay, super.
Alina auf dem Weg zu ihrer ersten Vernehmung.
Man braucht Fingerspitzengefühl, um das Opfer nicht zu überfordern.
Und dennoch alle wichtigen Informationen zu kriegen.
Aus Ermittlungsgründen dürfen wir die Vernehmung nicht zeigen.
Logischerweise macht das die Kollegin, die hat da viel Erfahrung und ich natürlich nicht.
Deswegen habe ich da zum ersten Mal niemandem erstmal nur zugehört.
Der nächste Fall.
Schon wieder eine komplett neue Situation für Alina.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir tatsächlich schwierig vorstelle?
Also auch so im normalen Polizeialltag.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Hilfestellen oder sonst was gibt.
Da gibt es doch sicherlich auch mal den einen...
Also was weiß ich, wenn du im Krankenhaus arbeitest, ist es wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Also ähnlich gelagert.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das auch...
Manche Fälle, die ein bisschen näher gehen.
Als man das gerne hätte.
Also es gibt ja immer mal wieder Situationen, wo du dich da irgendwie persönlich...
Also wo du dir das zu Herzen nimmst.
Und...
Was weiß ich...
Also wenn du das dann...
Keine Ahnung, 10, 20 Jahre machst...
Da besteht schon die Chance, dass du ziemlich einen Knacks irgendwann hast.
Weil ich meine...
Die...
Alleine schon, was sich die YouTube- und Facebook-Uploadprüfer angucken müssen.
An krankem Scheiß.
Das sitzt vielleicht bei der Polizei nicht in dieser Frequenz.
Aber wenn, dann ist es teilweise richtig heftiges Zeug.
Also das könnte ich mir schon vorstellen.
Da kriegst du wirklich Probleme mit der Zeit.
Also der Versuch war jetzt erfolgreich.
Da fahren wir drei jetzt gut hin.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich mir tatsächlich schwierig vorstelle?
Also wenn die wirklich Leute haben wollen, die Ahnung von IT haben,
dann ist eine Polizeiausbildung wahrscheinlich das Wenigste, was die machen.
Also das, wo die am wenigsten Bock drauf haben.
Wenn ich mir den 0815 IT-Pro vorstelle,
den kannst du verjagen, wenn du ihm sagst, mach mal eine Polizeiausbildung.
Also dann ist das ja vorbei.
Mit Alina.
Also wenn die zu mir sagen würden, Max, du musst jetzt auf einen Schießstand
und danach irgendwie ein paar Kilometer rennen oder sowas, keine Ahnung,
dann würde ich sagen, na gut, ihr könnt mich gerne haben.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es wahrscheinlich dort auch beides.
Also ich denke mal, dass es dort sicherlich auch Kellerkinder wie mich gibt,
die dann quasi diesen ganzen Krempel, was Alina unter anderem mitnimmt, analysieren.
Also du brauchst halt Leute, die Ahnung haben von beidem.
Du brauchst Leute, die quasi ein bisschen Ahnung von Polizei haben und ein bisschen Ahnung von Technik haben.
Oder sagen wir mal so, ganz gut Ahnung, nicht ein bisschen,
ganz gut Ahnung von Polizei haben und ganz gut Ahnung von Technik haben,
dass sie sowas machen können wie, welche Datenträger nehmen wir jetzt mit?
Oder hier ist ein laufender Computer, den schalten wir jetzt nicht einfach aus,
den überbrücken wir jetzt irgendwie mit einer USV und nehmen den mit und sowas in der Richtung.
Genau, das denke ich auch.
Ich denke auch, die haben, sie haben Kellerkinder wie mich in der Forensik
und die haben dann so Hybrid-Polizisten.
Hybrid-Polizisten und Techniker für so nicht direkt an der Front,
aber für so nach der Front quasi.
Abstimmung, okay.
Ja, Max, Sirius Max, gib ihm Abstimmung.
Wer würde die Ausbildung machen?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Also ich ganz klar nein, ich würde es nicht machen.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf Leute zu schießen
und ich habe keinen Bock so diese, diese, tja,
bisschen Militär-Style-Ausbildungen zu machen,
wobei, nee, nicht wirklich.
Polizei-Style-Ausbildung zu machen.
Also ich würde es nicht machen.
Sollte man das jetzt, es ist zu spät, jetzt läuft die Abstimmung schon.
Wie kann ich einen Rechner mit einer USV überbrücken?
Ja, du kannst, du kannst irgendwie gucken, dass du, gute Frage,
keine Ahnung, wie man das gescheit macht.
Da musst du wahrscheinlich am Haus irgendwie an die,
irgendwie was an der Steckdose machen.
Es gibt definitiv, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, Möglichkeiten dafür.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man es machen würde.
Da gibt es garantiert was.
Du kriegst keine Stelle, die suchen noch wie verrückt überall,
du suchst eine Ausbildung, ne?
Aber sogar Azubis werden doch eigentlich überall gesucht.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, wo du, wo du, wo du wohnst, oder?
Dass es da nichts gibt, weil ansonsten, wenn man bei uns in Frankfurt zum Beispiel guckt,
also wo du hinspuckst, ist ein Rechenzentrum
und auch ganz viele Leute, die ausbilden.
Okay, also, wir können ungefähr sagen,
ähm, so, ja, ein Viertel, ein Viertel könnte sich das vorstellen
und drei Viertel sagen eher, nee, keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, so ungefähr hätte ich mir das Ergebnis auch vorgestellt.
Und bearbeitet es.
Machen wir.
Packen wir das schön zusammen und dann fahren wir los.
Der Typ sieht übelst aus wie Captain Price, nur ein bisschen dicker.
Guckt euch mal, nur mal so zum Vergleich, also,
Guckt euch den,
Guckt euch den Dude an und dann guckt euch
Captain
Price an.
Nicht, nicht, nicht den Captain Price, den Captain Price.
Moment, wo sind wir?
Ah.
Erkennt ihr nicht, dass das,
das sieht, der sieht dem schon ähnlich.
Und nicht der Pausbacken-Price aus dem CGI.
Nee.
Klar, der sieht dem total ähnlich.
Alter, Chat.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich finde von den Augen her, von,
ich seh dem, egal, ihr.
Chat.
Packen wir das schön zusammen und dann fahren wir los.
Mach mal.
Alina soll beim Untersuchen der Leiche helfen.
Im Einsatz zählt sie nun schon als vollwertiges Teammitglied.
Na, das habe ich so, das, also, die Aussage, da habe ich da so meine Zweifel dran.
Vorher noch ein Satz, unsere Praktikantin kommt mit.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel dran, ja.
Es ist natürlich schon ein anderes Gefühl, ja.
So, das erste Mal, wenn man tatsächlich so das Holz am Gürtel hat,
da fühlt man sich tatsächlich so das erste Mal richtig bei der Polizei.
Weil davor, ja.
Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock draus, mit Pistole rumlaufen zu wollen.
Aber wenn man dann tatsächlich das erste Mal so rausgeht,
schon immer ein anderes Gefühl dann, das stimmt.
Gleich wird Alina ihre erste Leiche als Polizistin sehen.
Muss Alina eigentlich auch das, das Polizeisportdingsprogramm und so machen?
Da hätte ich ja überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn man das das erste Mal macht, hat man da schon Berührungsängste,
das ist völlig normal.
Dann kommt es natürlich auch noch auf den Zustand vom Leichnam an.
Da gibt es ja bestimmte Stadien,
da kann man ja nicht so sehr das Leichenzustand,
das sage ich jetzt mal vorsichtig.
Aber in dem Fall ist es ein sehr frischer Leichnam.
Aber sie muss das auch nicht machen.
Sie wird nur Protokoll führen.
Und entweder die Theresa oder ich werden den haptischen Teil abdecken.
Den haptischen Teil, schön umschrieben.
So, Alina, los geht's.
Alina arbeitet seit einigen Jahren als Rettungssanitäterin.
Dort ist ihr der Tod bereits begegnet.
Als Polizistin muss sie nun zum ersten Mal
bei einer Leiche auf Spuren achten.
Hast du die Fototaschen immer mit?
Genau.
Du hast die Formulare, die du dir überhaupt ...
Wunderbar.
Wir dürfen aus Rücksicht auf die Angehörigen nicht mehr zeigen.
Aber so viel ist klar, Alina hat den Einsatz gemeistert.
Auch dank ihrer Erfahrung aus dem Rettungsdienst.
Man achtet halt auf andere Sachen.
Also, ja, hier gucken wir jetzt halt auf ganz andere Dinge,
die mich halt im Rettungsdienst jetzt mal primär
nicht interessieren.
Von dem her, es ist halt eine andere Blickweise drauf, ja.
Okay, wann kommt denn der Cyber-Teil?
Der Beitrag ist jetzt schon zur Hälfte rum.
Wir hatten noch nicht einmal was mit Hacker und sonst was zu tun.
Fall für Alina noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Jetzt müssen wir den ganzen schriftlichen Teil machen.
Boah, allein schon das würde mich so abfacken,
dass ich das niemals machen würde.
Ich kriege bei mir auf der Arbeit schon Zustände,
wenn ich da irgendwelche Sachen ausfüllen muss,
Retrospektiven machen muss, irgendwelche Besprechungen und sonst wie.
Auf diesen ganzen Papierkram, da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Da am Computer ausfüllen und die Bilder, die wir gemacht haben,
alles quasi ...
Und danach das Ganze per Fax verschicken zum Archivieren.
Einpflegen, dass man das dann weiterleiten kann.
Auch Formulare gehören zum Polizei-Alltag.
Klingt zwar langweilig, ist aber wichtig,
um Erkenntnisse vor Gericht überhaupt nutzen zu können.
Was Alina hier lernt, wird sich schon bald auszahlen.
Die Quereinsteigerin soll die komplette Polizeiarbeit kennenlernen,
nicht nur ihren späteren Bereich Cybercrime.
Es wäre ja sinnvoll, in der Ausbildung
sich ein bisschen auf Cybercrime zu fokussieren, oder?
Weil ich meine, letztendlich soll sie es ja später machen.
Weil ich sage mal, in unseren vier Monaten in Laar
kriegt man ja immer nur so ein paar Sachen an die Hand,
die man dann hinterfragt.
Was man in der Praxis vielleicht irgendwie braucht.
Ja, ich habe IT studiert im Polizei,
hat man halt davor gar nichts zu tun,
hat man keine so wirklichen Vorstellungen.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt tatsächlich mal in der Praxis erlebt,
wie es halt wirklich in den verschiedenen Bereichen
tatsächlich funktioniert,
zumindest, dass man einen kleinen Einblick da bekommt,
ist schon spannend.
Und schon die ersten Einblicke zeigen,
Alina wird es später in der Cyberunit
auch mit schweren Schicksalen zu tun bekommen.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Grüß dich, wir haben eine Suizidandrohung.
Oh, okay.
Was kannst du mir geben an Daten?
Jetzt oben hast du mal eine IP-Adresse.
Ja.
Deinen Zeitstempel.
Okay.
Eine Suizidandrohung.
Also, wenn irgendeiner auf Twitter schreibt,
ich bringe mich um, geht's, kommt mal um.
Okay.
17.02.2002.
Stand da an der Tür gerade Herr Facebook.
Okay, Moment.
Herr Facebook.
Tatsächlich.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Einzige,
der den direkten Draht zu Facebook hat
und Sachen rausbekommt.
Ey, muss ja nicht mal Boomerhumor sein.
Es kann durchaus Boomerhumor sein.
Aber wer weiß,
vielleicht ist der da immer beim Zug anrufen muss
und sagen, Jungs,
könnt ihr mal die IP-Adresse raussuchen?
Jetzt, Gücker, hi.
Grüß dich, wir haben eine Suizidandrohung.
Oh, okay.
Was kannst du mir geben an Daten?
Jetzt oben hast du mal eine IP-Adresse.
Ja.
Deinen Zeitstempel.
Okay.
17.02.2022.
Ja.
Kriminalhauptkommissar Thomas Ramel hat einen neuen Fall.
Ah, Telekom.
Telekom-IP, oder?
Telekom-IP?
80127?
Ne, 80182.
Telekom-IP?
Neuen Fall.
Der Betreiber eines sozialen Netzwerks
hat den Ermittlern einen Suizidverdacht gemeldet.
So etwas kommt hier fast jede Woche vor.
Die Polizisten versuchen den Notfall...
Nur jede Woche?
Ich hätte gedacht,
es ist wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit so was.
...ausfindig zu machen,
bevor es zu spät ist.
...ob es da irgendwelche personenbezogenen Daten gibt,
sprich Geburtsdatum,
ob er das angegeben hat,
oder vielleicht einen Mietname,
dass wir vielleicht mit dem auch weiterkommen können.
Alles dabei.
Okay, super.
Stell euch mal vor,
stell euch mal vor,
ihr postet auf Facebook irgendwas Blödes
und auf einmal ruft die Polizei bei euch an.
So leben sie noch?
Ja, okay.
Was denkst du dir denn dann?
Na gut, auf der anderen Seite,
jetzt mal Spaß beiseite,
natürlich ist das vom Grundgedanke her eine super Geschichte.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Erfolgsquote ist,
aber die werden sicherlich schon den ein oder anderen gerettet haben,
auf diese Art und Weise.
Also ich finde gut, dass so was verfolgt wird.
Nicht falsch verstehen, ja.
Die Cyberunit im LKA
klärt Straftaten auf und versucht sie auch zu verhindern.
Wir haben die Aufgabe zu gucken,
dass das Internet keinen straffreien Raum darstellt.
Ich hasse diese Redewendung.
Das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein, bla bla.
Das ist die schlimmste Redewendung überhaupt in dieser Richtung.
Das Internet war noch nie ein rechtsfreier Raum.
Gut, wenn die Polizei das sagt,
ist das natürlich was anderes.
Allgemein wird ja immer darüber diskutiert,
so nach dem Motto,
als gäbe es einfach nur nicht die richtigen Gesetze
und so was in der Richtung.
Aber wenn die Polizei das sagt,
heißt es ja im Endeffekt,
damit das Internet kein rechtsfreier Raum ist,
müssen sie halt was machen.
Weil wenn die Polizei nichts macht,
würde ja sonst keiner was machen.
Aber diese Aussage an sich,
das triggert mich immer,
das war es noch nie.
Wir versuchen auch selber zu gucken,
in welchen Diensten passieren Straftaten.
Das fängt an,
Darknet,
sehr großer Bereich,
den man nicht außer Acht lassen sollte,
mit allen Phänomenen, die es darin gibt,
Rauschgift,
BTM,
Kinderpornografie,
Waffen,
Falschgeld,
bis hin zu Unterstützungen.
Alter, richtiger Boomer-Hintergrund.
Wenn jetzt die Kollegen und Kolleginnen draußen hier anrufen,
ich habe mal eine Frage zu sozialen Netzwerken.
Was gibt es da für Möglichkeiten?
Da unterstützen wir sie natürlich auch.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
dann meldet euch bei uns
und dann können wir noch mal kurz drüber reden.
Dankeschön. Ciao.
Ah, die guten modernen Telefone.
Wir sind auch im Bereich Cyber-Grooming aktiv.
Das heißt, wir geben uns als 12-jähriges Kind aus.
Es ist erschreckend,
was da passiert in dem Bereich.
Ich vergleiche es immer so,
wenn man ein Stück Fleisch in den Amazonas reinschmeißt
und die Piranhas kommen.
So kann man sich das tatsächlich vorstellen.
An einen schweren Fall kann sich Thomas Rammel gut erinnern.
Über Kinderpornos kamen die Ermittler
zu einem Sexualstraftäter auf die Spur.
Mit mehr Manpower könnten wir viel mehr solche Verfahren initiieren
und beginnen und ermitteln.
Insofern würde uns schon ein gewisses Personal gut tun.
Das glaube ich demgleich.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es bei der Polizei prinzipiell wie in fast allen Bereichen ist,
dass es einfach schlicht und ergreifend zu wenig Leute gibt.
Geht in Pflege, Krankenhaus, sonst wie, Kindergarten.
Es gibt überall zu wenig Leute.
Zu wenig Leute heißt ja wahrscheinlich auch zu wenig Geld.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder zu wenig Geld oder sie finden einfach keine Leute.
Wenn man einfach keine Leute findet,
muss man gucken, woran es liegt.
Wenn es zu wenig Geld gibt, kann man einfacher etwas ändern.
Wahrscheinlich geht es denen ähnlich wie vielen anderen Bereichen.
Die suchen händeringend Leute.
Ich glaube dem sofort,
dass man da deutlich mehr machen könnte
mit mehr Leuten.
Die uns da mit ihrem Know-how,
weil sie auch viel technisches Know-how haben,
da extrem unterstützen können.
Wo sind eigentlich die Hacker?
Der Beitrag geht noch 10 Minuten.
... öfter arbeiten in der Cyber-Einheit des LKA in Stuttgart.
Ah, jetzt. Jetzt kommen die Hacker.
... im Bereich Wirtschaftskriminalität im Netz.
Die Opfer sind Unternehmen, die gehackt wurden.
Zentrale Ansprechstelle Cybercrime
für Unternehmen und Behörden in Baden-Württemberg.
Guten Tag.
Wo sind Sie ansässig?
Das ist doch jetzt gestellt, der Anruf, oder?
Das ist doch gestellt.
... Unternehmen?
In Stuttgart.
Es haben sich bei uns schon verzweifelte Geschäftsführer
sicher an uns gewendet.
Es haben sich Rechtsanwälte von Unternehmen an uns gewendet,
die betroffen waren und haben die Situationen dargestellt.
Und natürlich auch das massive Ausmaß,
das heißt die konkrete Betroffenheit.
Die müssen das ja auch melden.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob man das der Polizei melden muss.
Aber man muss es ja mittlerweile auch melden,
wenn du Kundendaten und Sachen verloren hast.
Wobei ich glaube, weiß nicht, ob die Polizei was damit zu tun hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Also manchmal bist du ja sogar verpflichtet, Sachen zu melden.
... betriebswirtschaftlichen Prozess.
Und einige dieser Unternehmen befinden sich aufgrund dieser Angriffe
oder beispielsweise aufgrund der hohen Summen,
die betrügerisch erlangt gezahlt wurden,
in ja tatsächlich...
Ja, seriously.
Also wer Ransomware Trojaner bezahlt,
der hätte mal wirklich ein bisschen früher
bei der Cyber-Einheit anrufen sollen.
Also das kann ich nicht...
Also wenn wirklich irgendjemand
Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner-Bitcoin-Shit bezahlt,
dem ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen.
Bis zu sieben...
Aber wie war das?
Keine Backups, kein Mitleid, oder?
... Millionen US-Dollar haben einzelne Unternehmen
als Lösegeld für ihre Daten schon gezahlt,
erinnert sich Seeberg.
Die Fälle häufen sich.
Mittlerweile hat sich das eingependelt
auf circa 1.800 bis 1.900 Kontaktierungen jährlich.
Das heißt, betroffene Unternehmen,
die sich über E-Mail anfragen oder telefonisch anrufen,
müssen an uns wenden.
Und dieses hohe Ausmaß...
Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
In Berlin gab es doch so eine Cybercrime-Hotline,
wo man anrufen konnte,
die sich halt überhaupt nicht lohnt,
weil da nie jemand anruft.
... verdeutlichen die aktuelle Cybercrime-Bedrohungslage
für den Wirtschaftsstandort in Baden-Württemberg.
Und wie ist die?
Ja, tatsächlich ist diese akut.
Es ist eine grundsätzliche Bedrohung generell gegeben.
Im aktuellen Ukraine...
Eine grundsätzliche Bedrohung ist immer da.
Mach einen virtuellen Server an
und lauscht mal mit,
was da so für Anfragen auf dem SSH-Port kommen.
Das ist normal.
Das war aber im Prinzip schon immer so.
Sobald du was ins Internet hängst
oder vom Internet zugänglich machst,
ist immer was da.
Grundrauschen den ganzen Tag.
Kriegskontext selbstverständlich verstärkt.
Der Chat, dem sein Job ist,
ist mit Sicherheit auch nicht überflüssig.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann.
Also ich finde das wichtig,
dass wir Leute haben,
die davon Ahnung haben,
die sich um sowas kümmern.
Man kann sich sicherlich
über die gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen und Sachen,
die da passieren, beschweren.
Gerade die letzten Jahre über
immer wieder diese Geschichte mit
Verschlüsselung soll untersagt werden.
Alles, was verschlüsselt ist,
ist standardmäßig verdächtig.
Und immer wieder die gleiche Leier,
so nach dem Motto,
ja, man muss das und das abschaffen
wegen Morden und Kinderpornos und sonst wie.
Weil man halt da wenig,
auch emotional, ja,
niemand wird das verteidigen.
Da werden alle immer sagen,
standardmäßig so,
ja, ja, ist wichtig, muss man machen.
Aber man muss sich ja auch mal
das Verhältnis angucken
und man kann nicht alles immer damit begründen.
Weil du wirst im Prinzip nie,
du wirst,
entweder wirst du absolut keine Freiheiten mehr haben
und alles überwachen
oder umgedreht.
Also wir wollen beide Extreme nicht.
Also ich zumindest nicht.
Ich will weder hundertprozentige Freiheit
in allen Bereichen
noch komplette Überwachung.
Leider ist es mittlerweile so,
dass ich meine persönliche Meinung,
ja, dass ich es in vielen Bereichen
etwas zu pauschal in Richtung
man muss das verbieten,
man müsste Verschlüsselung aufbrechen können,
dass ich das zu sehr verschiebt.
Ja, die letzten Jahre über.
Das fing an mit
wir müssen Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen
und mittlerweile ist es so,
dass solche Daten missbraucht werden
für sowas wie RedTube-Abmahnwellen und sowas.
Der Typ hat aber,
und das muss man sagen,
das finde ich wenigstens gut,
dass sowas noch,
ja, nicht ungestraft passiert dann,
diese RedTube-Abmahntypen,
die haben ja richtig Einlauf bekommen.
Also wer sich da nicht mehr daran erinnert,
es gab mal irgendeine Anwaltskanzlei,
die war der Meinung,
hey,
wir gehen jetzt zum Richter
und lassen uns das absegnen,
dass wir die IPs bekommen
von irgendwelchen Pornoseiten-Benutzern
und denen haben sie dann Abmahnungen geschickt.
Und im Nachhinein hat sich rausgestellt,
die haben das halt so geschickt gemacht,
dass dem Richter nicht so klar war,
was er da eigentlich unterschreibt.
Und ich glaube,
die haben mittlerweile alle ihre Lizenz verloren.
Also das ist,
das dauert vielleicht ein bisschen,
aber die lassen sich definitiv nicht gerne verarschen.
Krieg zu bestehen benötigt die Polizei
das IT-Wissen der Quereinsteiger.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal,
denkt mal,
guckt euch irgendwas an auf irgendeiner Website
und auf einmal kriegt ihr eine Abmahnung geschickt,
weil ihr irgendeinen Porn gestreamt habt oder so.
Und im Zweifelsfall dann ist eure IP
noch auf richterliche Anordnung rausgegeben worden.
Also das war schon ein starkes Stück.
Konntest du schon das 9-Euro-Ticket nutzen?
Nö.
An der Hochschule für Polizei in Böblingen
laufen Alinas Kurse nun auf die großen Prüfungen zu.
Heute beschäftigt sich Alina mit digitaler Forensik.
Mit einem praktischen Beispiel.
Das sieht sehr analog aus bis jetzt.
Falschgeld.
Also was ist daran denn jetzt digital, Monka S.?
Man muss sich einfach, ich sage mal im Klaren sein,
die Banknote ist auf Deutsch gesagt der Ferrari
für die ganze Sicherheitstechnologie.
Warum?
Weil da ist auf der Vorder- oder Vorderrückseite
alles reingepackt, was es an Sicherheitsmerkmalen gibt.
Und bei den Ideedokumenten, Pässen und so weiter
versucht man das in irgendeiner Form zu übertragen.
Ja, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel so etwas wie neuerdings
Fingerabdrücke auf Personalausweisen,
was ich richtig beschissen finde.
Das ist auch so etwas, wo es sich leider in die Richtung entwickelt,
die ich nicht haben will.
Wir gucken mal so, ob wir Unterschiede finden
zu dem echten Schein jetzt.
Aber mit digital hat das jetzt wenig zu tun, oder?
Eine gute Fälschung.
Aber so mit Falschgeld und so Forensik,
hat das auch noch nichts zu tun, oder?
Nein, gar nichts.
Als Laie merkt man das ja für gewöhnlich auch gar nicht,
wenn man da nicht darauf achten muss.
Ja, das ist total spannend.
Weil das sind ja schon wirklich gut gemachte Sachen.
Und ich meine, das kann einem ja auch privat irgendwann passieren,
dass man so etwas unterjubelt bekommt.
Denn er hat es ja gesagt, dass es ganz vielen einfach nicht auffällt,
weil sie halt nicht wissen, worauf sie achten müssen.
Einfach Bitcoin verwenden, dann hat man das Problem nicht mehr.
Also, das ist schon spannend, dass wir uns das jetzt mal anschauen.
Die angehenden Cybercops sollen zwischen dem Falschgeld,
Druckbildern und Druckerdaten Verbindungen herstellen.
Oh, da ist ein Laptop, Leute.
Jetzt weiß ich, jetzt ist es klar.
... später mögliche Täter überführen.
Auch gefälschte Pässe,
müssen die Ermittler später erkennen
und mit beschlagnahmten Druckern von einer Durchsuchung zusammenbringen.
Wie man draufdruckt, druckt man genau in dieser Farbe drauf.
Mein Raster bleibt auf.
Seht ihr hier die Sollbruchstelle?
Guckt mal da in der Mitte, seht ihr das?
Guckt ihr mal da?
Das kann mit eurer Lupe aussehen.
Praktisch zwei Teile zusammengeklebt.
Und damit wisst ihr definitiv,
ja, das geht bei jedem Pass, bei jedem Papier geht es.
Falschgelddrucker, Cybermobbing, Hacker, das Einsatzgebiet der Cybercops.
Also seriously, außer diese zwei Worte jetzt
ist in diesem ganzen Beitrag nichts mit Hacker und Cybercop passiert.
Es ist komplex.
Wenn Sie heute in einen Tatortgang gehen,
früher war es so ganz konventionell mit Fingerabdrücken, mit Blut und, und, und.
Was hat der da am Mund hängen?
Was heute in der Wohnung alles vorhanden ist.
Ich habe auch fast in jedem Zimmer Alexa stehen.
Nee, ich nicht.
Man weiß, was ein Drucker abspeichert.
Man weiß, was ein Kopierer abspeichert.
Mein Drucker speichert vor allem verkrustete Tinte ab.
Also das war die bescheuertste Idee überhaupt, mir einen Tintenschalldrucker zu kaufen.
Was der Kühlschrank alles macht.
Diese Spuren sind dankbar.
Da gehen wir zu einem Auto, wenn man die Autounfälle ansieht.
Als Tesla-Fahrer ist alles dokumentiert.
Alina muss ihr IT-Wissen auf die Ermittlungsarbeit übertragen.
Das finde ich auch nicht gut.
Nicht alles, was ein Informatiker kann, darf ein Polizist laut Gesetz.
In ihrer Klasse hat Alina Gleichgesinnte gefunden.
Alle haben sich gegen eine Karriere in der Wirtschaft und für den Staatsdienst entschieden.
Das schweißt zusammen.
Warum?
Mich würde tatsächlich interessieren, warum.
Abends zusammensetzen, irgendwie was lernen zusammen.
Oder auch mal abends einfach nur Spiele spielen.
Ich finde, das muss auch mal sein einfach.
Aber langsam steigt die Anspannung in der Klasse.
Die Abschlussprüfungen stehen an.
Alina übt sich in Gelassenheit.
Essen ist gut.
Man ist ja mit den ganzen Leuten aus seiner Klasse im Endeffekt hier.
Und man kann sich tatsächlich auch gut aufs Lernen konzentrieren.
Daheim finde ich das mit der Ableckung manchmal so eine Sache.
Aber hier funktioniert das ganz gut.
In ein paar Wochen entscheidet sich, ob Alina die Prüfung zur Kommissarin besteht.
Ja, aber wo sind denn jetzt die Hacker und das Cyber-Kram?
Ihr letztes Praktikum hat sie auf dem Kommissariat in Waiblingen.
Cybercop, das ist zwar viel Arbeit am Computer.
Ja, dann zeigt uns mal was.
Aber die kann trotzdem sehr spannend sein.
Alina hat Handydaten von einem Autounfall ausgewertet.
Na, wie kommt's vorwärts?
Ja, ich bin jetzt gerade noch in den letzten Zügen, die ganzen Daten auszuwerten.
Das heißt, wenn du nachher Zeit hast, können wir vielleicht mal...
Also, das ist eine gute Antwort.
Das hat sie bestimmt in der IT gelernt.
Sie hat jetzt ja quasi umschrieben gesagt, da sind wir dran.
Wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck an der Lösung des Problems, hat sie gerade gesagt.
...gehen, was ich so rausgefunden habe.
Wir sind völlig fertig.
Dann werde ich danach einen Bericht weitermachen.
Okay, gib schon mal 10 Minuten.
Dann würde ich sagen, setzen wir uns oben in den Besprechungsraum.
Hat der Fahrer sein Handy während der Fahrt benutzt?
Millionen von Einzeldaten hat Alina durchgeführt.
Auf der Suche nach dem entscheidenden Beweis, den sie vor Gericht verwenden kann.
Die Suche nach der Nadel im Datenheuhaufen.
Ja, dann zeig doch mal was. Beispiel.
Wie lang genau, kann ich tatsächlich gar nicht sagen.
Aber es waren schon drei Wochen mal bestimmt.
Und ja, wir haben tatsächlich auch was rausbekommen, was uns weiterhilft für den Fall.
Aber da musste ich mich auch einfach mal reinarbeiten.
Also, das hatte ich mich davor auch noch nie mit beschäftigt.
Was hast du denn jetzt gemacht?
Es waren schon auch einige Stunden, wo ich einfach mal hinhocken musste und gucken, okay, was könnte das überhaupt sein?
Ja, was geht da? Hat die Bilder durchgeguckt?
Oder was hast du denn gemacht jetzt?
Also, was ist denn jetzt konkret das, was hier in diesem Fall der Cybercop macht?
Wo finde ich da vielleicht auch Infos?
Ich meine, IT entwickelt sich halt immer weiter.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt halt nicht so, dass man einfach ein Buch aufschlägt und sagt, super, da steht's.
Alinas Erkenntnisse könnten in einem späteren Gerichtsverfahren den entscheidenden Unterschied machen.
Also, das ist jetzt mal alles komplett nichtssagender Blödsinn gewesen.
Der Fahrer hat sein Handy während der Fahrt offensichtlich benutzt.
Ja.
Wir haben das Ganze einfach noch mal simuliert, nachgestellt und dann eben überprüft, stimmen eben die Events miteinander überein.
Und das dann eben verglichen haben, ob das wirklich so passiert sein kann.
Okay. Also, es ist ausgeschlossen, dass gerade dieser Event hier im passiven Modus tatsächlich, wenn er einfach fährt mit dem Auto...
Ah.
...irgendeinem...
Der Typ ist irgendwo dagegen gefahren.
Und man vermutet, jetzt hat er auf dem Handy rumgedrückt und nicht geguckt.
...Nachricht, die eingeht oder so. Okay.
Genau, ja. Das haben wir eigentlich alle soweit getestet.
Von dem her, ja. Also, es muss im Endeffekt wirklich genau so gewesen sein.
Wir haben den Fall damals zusammen angefangen.
Und sie ist sofort dann selbstständig und eigenständig an die Arbeit gegangen.
Sie war da echt straight forward.
Hat zum Teil auf Urlaub verzichtet, um den Fall fertig zu bringen.
Das ist das, was ich zum Beispiel nie machen würde.
Man muss da wahrscheinlich gewisse höhere Berufung haben dafür.
Und wenn du danach ein Ergebnis hast, das du dann, sag ich mal, gerichtsvorwertbar dann und vielleicht sogar vor Gericht dann vertreten kannst, ist das unglaublich wichtig.
Und es gibt einem echt ein gutes Gefühl, wenn du dann abends hier rausläufst, dass du denkst, jawohl, du hast jetzt wieder die Welt ein kleines bisschen besser und gerechter gemacht.
Und Alina hat sich da echt super geschlagen.
Mit diesem Erfolgserlebnis geht Alina in ihre Abschlussprüfungen.
Bei den Prüfungen dürfen wir nicht dabei sein.
Alina besteht.
Und wir treffen sie einige Tage später bei ihrer Verbeamtung wieder.
Für mich war das härteste, dass man sich einfach in die Sichtweise von einem Polizisten reindenkt.
Weil wir ja bei den Prüfungen beispielsweise Fallbeispiele bekommen, die wir dann entsprechend abarbeiten müssen.
Und da war es das ein oder andere Mal schon so, dass man sich überlegt hat, naja, als ITler würde ich vielleicht so oder so vorgehen.
Und aber eben gefragt war, wie man da jetzt als Polizist rangeht.
Vielleicht klappt das deswegen auch oftmals nicht.
Weil man zu wenig als ITler rangeht.
Großer Tag.
Sie wird nach dieser anstrengenden Zeit zur Kommissarin ernannt.
Aber seriously, da war ja nichts in diesem ganzen Video. Wirklich Hacker.
Vom LKA-Präsidenten persönlich.
Das ist natürlich ein sehr schöner Moment.
Ich meine, im Endeffekt habe ich das komplette Jahr ja quasi zu diesem Tag hingearbeitet.
Die ganzen Prüfungen dafür geschrieben, dass ich jetzt eben heute zur Kriminalkommissarin ernannt werden kann.
Bad Wittenberg-Urkunde.
Ich ernenne Frau Alina.
Ich ernenne Frau Alina Wiepern mit Wirkung vom 1. April 2022 in der Prüfung des Beamtenverhältnisses auf Probe zur Kriminalkommissarin.
Ich gelobe, dass ich mein Amt nach bestem Wissen und Können führe,
das Grundgesetz für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
die Landesverfassung und das Recht achten und verteidigen,
und Gerechtigkeit...
Alina kann durchstarten.
Im Dienst der baden-wittenbergischen Cyberpolizei beim Landeskriminalamt.
Das war Ihre Vereinigung.
Wunderbar.
Und ich erwarte, dass sie mit dazu beiträgt, dass wir uns bei der Bekämpfung der Cyberkriminalität
auch in fachlicher Hinsicht kontinuierlich weiterentwickeln können.
Also da hat man jetzt leider nicht so viel davon gesehen im Video.
Sehr gut. Ich freue mich, dass ich mich jetzt Kriminalkommissarin nennen darf.
Jetzt ist das Jahr rum, jetzt ist man tatsächlich im Job und tatsächlich eben im Amt.
Frau Wiepern, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Dankeschön.
Gratuliere.
Gebrophistet, Alter.
Ich hab noch was für Sie.
Wobei, das müssen die wahrscheinlich machen wegen Corona noch.
Als Kriminalkommissarin müssen Sie auch erkennbar sein.
Und dafür überreiche ich Ihnen unser Etui der Kriminalpolizei,
mit dem Sie sich dann ausweisen können, können Sie Ihren Dienstausweis reinmachen
und das Sie bei Einsätzen tragen werden.
Ja. Vielen Dank.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Dankeschön.
Tja. Ups. Das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht anklicken.
Also man hat wenig gesehen. Man hat keine Ahnung, was die wirklich genau machen.
Keine Ahnung. Zumindest, was man hier gesehen hat, ist wenig, wenig, was im...
Also im Prinzip stand in diesem Titel...
Also alles, was in diesem Titel stand, kam mehr oder weniger nicht dran.
Also es ging weder um Hacker, noch so wirklich um Cyber-Kram.
Ja. Weiß nicht. Also ich finde, das hat jetzt nicht gerade Werbung dafür gemacht,
dass sich da jetzt mehr Leute bewerben.
Außer mit Technik-Hintergrund.
Ups.
Ganz ehrlich, also ich bezahle lieber für sowas GEZ.
Also am liebsten würde ich natürlich gar keine bezahlen.
Zumal eine GEZ gibt es ja immer mehr. Aber kommt aufs Gleiche aus.
Also ich bezahle lieber GEZ für sowas, als für Rosamunde Pilcher.
Also laut dem Video hat Alina nicht einen Hacker gejagt.
Ja. Das ist wohl wahr.
Aber gerade Wirtschaftsinformatik...
Den Wirtschaftsteil brauchst du doch ja da gar nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also mich persönlich hätte es jetzt nicht angesprochen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es chillig ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es relativ belastend ist.
Man, neben der eigentlichen Belastung im Job, was man da nicht vergessen darf,
ist, dass im Prinzip, ich will jetzt nicht sagen die ganze Welt, das ist übertrieben,
dass quasi ganz Deutschland darauf guckt, ob du was verkackst.
Das ist das, was du da auch nicht unterschätzen darfst, finde ich.
Also egal, was du machst.
Wenn du irgendwie einmal halbwegs öffentlichkeitswirksam was verkehrt machst, bist du im Arsch.
Oder hast riesige Probleme.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das chilliges Leben ist im Endeffekt.
Also ich glaube, du brauchst, dass du Polizist wirst.
Ich meine, reich bist du davon wahrscheinlich jener.
Ich glaube, du brauchst als Polizist einen gewissen Antrieb dazu.
Eine gewisse persönliche Überzeugung.
Und Antrieb, dass du das überhaupt machst.
Ne, habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Ich habe gestern auf dem Handy zwei, drei Minuten reingeguckt.
Und ganz ehrlich, im Prinzip genauso, wie ich es mir von Facebook erwartet hätte.
Und was, was bestimmt auch deutsche Unternehmen machen würden,
wenn sie nicht Schiss davor haben müssten, richtig Probleme zu bekommen.
Ja, das ist, das sieht man ja jetzt schon.
Guckt euch die Leute an, die bei YouTube und Facebook die Uploads filtern müssen.
Da, da haben wir ja auch vor, vor einer Weile mal ein Video drüber gesehen.
Von Leuten, die richtig krass Belastungen, also die, die konnten nicht mal richtig schlafen und alles.
Aber ich kann es auch verstehen.
Überlegt euch mal.
Das, was wir auf YouTube sehen, ist ja schon teilweise etwas verstörend.
Aber noch im legalen und verträglichen Bereich.
Das, was die ganzen Upload-Filter-Leute sehen, die bekommen ja quasi zum größten Teil auch die Dinger,
die schon vorgefilterter Bullshit sind.
Und du musst dir den abartigsten Dreck aller Wegen,
Dreck aller Zeiten angucken, wenn du im Facebook oder YouTube Content-Sichtungsteam bist.
Da musst du wahrscheinlich im Minutentakt, du kannst gar nicht so viel kotzen, wie du kotzen müsstest.
Das kann ich verstehen, dass die Leute da richtig krass psychische Probleme kriegen.
Und bei der Polizei hast du wahrscheinlich auch einiges an abartigem Zeug.
Weil da kriegst du ja erstmal die Sachen, wovon man schon von ausgeht, dass sie illegal sind.
Dass sie keine Details zeigen durften, ja dann ist der Beitrag aber maximal Unsinn.
Maximal unsinnig, den so zu nennen, ja.
Hätte man das eher nennen sollen, eine Informatik-Absolventin wird Polizistin.
Weil ansonsten, es war ja im Prinzip nichts damit wirklich Zusammenhang zu bringen.
Na, da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Man ist da ohne Scheiß, man ist da relativ schnell dabei, zu sagen,
ah ja, ich habe doch im Internet schon alles gesehen, mich schockt es nicht mehr, Leute.
Wir können uns so pauschal gar nicht ausmalen, was für krankes Zeug Leute machen und filmen und hochladen.
Da ist alles dabei.
Und da ist Leute, die sich ankacken, noch das Kleinste, was du dir anschauen musst.
Du musst dir angucken, wenn du in diesem, nur mal so ein paar Beispiele, die mir so aus dem Kopf einfallen, ja.
Ähm, du musst dir angucken, wie Leute bei lebendigem Leib verbrannt werden.
Und rumschreien.
Das ist schon was, was belastend sein kann auf Dauer, ja.
Äh, und, und, von anderen Sachen haben wir gar nicht, also, das ist krasser, krasser Shit, was es da gibt, ja.
Und, wenn du dir das den ganzen Tag geben musst, gut, vielleicht interessiert dich ja gar nichts,
kann ja sein, dass sich das alles nicht, nicht, ähm, ähm, nicht schockt.
Aber ich denke, die meisten Leute lässt sowas nicht kalt.
Und, wenn du dir das den ganzen Tag gibst, für Monate und Jahre am Stück, du musst ja irgendwie einen seelischen Schaden kriegen.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht, ohne Scheiß.
Und, wie gesagt, ich rede jetzt von jemandem, der bei Facebook und YouTube, ähm, die, den Content sichtet.
Bei der Polizei ist das bestimmt ähnlich heftig, weil, was du da siehst, da geht man ja von aus, dass das schon illegal ist.
Und, äh, ja, aber ich guck kein Programm.
Ich guck auch, ich guck auch kein 4chan mehr regelmäßig.
Ja, also, 3chan ist schon heftig.
Also, man kann sich, wir können uns das jetzt auf, also, so auf, auf die ersten paar Gedanken können wir uns gar nicht, ähm, ausmalen, was für kranken Scheiß Leute machen, filmen und hochladen.
Ja, ja, ist auch, das ist auch wichtig.
Ganz ehrlich, lange hältst du das wahrscheinlich ohne psychologische Betreuung nicht aus.
Nächstes Video brauche ich ein wenig Pipo-Plan...
Ja, was haben wir denn hier für, für nette Videos? Zeig mal her.
Ähm...
Die neue bessere Form von Product Placements.
Not VPN.
Ob das besser ist?
New World, das, das ist mir zu lang, das Video.
Die dunkle Wahrheit über Bio-Label, das muss simplici...
Ja, klar, was sonst, äh.
Diese Titel.
Why a Mars Colony is a stupid and dangerous idea.
16 Minuten.
Okay, ganz einfach.
Ich kann euch sagen, warum eine Mars Kolonie, zumindest zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt, eine ziemlich blöde Idee ist.
Weil der Mars...
Eine ziemlich lebensfeindliche Umgebung ist.
Es gibt Experimente auf der Erde.
Mit Leuten in...
Keine Ahnung, in der Antarktis, in irgendwelchen Wüsten oder sonst wie.
Und damit gab es schon, das ist jetzt nicht neu, es gab die letzten, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 100 Jahre schon...
Immer mal wieder Versuche, wo man gesagt hat, hey, wir setzen jetzt irgendwie 10 Leute...
Irgendwo...
Ganz abseits der Zivilisation aus.
Und die müssen sich selbst versorgen.
Und ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass übrigens keines dieser...
Keines dieser Experimente ist...
Hat wirklich gut funktioniert.
Und ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass jedes...
Diese Experimente hier...
Die fehlgeschlagen sind, um ein vielfaches lebensfreundlicher war, als wenn man das ganze noch auf dem Mars machen würde.
So, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Also.
Elon Musk hier.
Voll von guten Ideen, die immer funktionieren.
Sag mir, wäre es nicht episch, wenn man das Ganze auf dem Mars machen würde?
Also.
Wäre es nicht episch, in einer Marskolonie zu leben?
Live auf der roten Frontiere?
Also.
Es wäre episch, in einer Marskolonie zu leben, wenn die Marskolonie schon so gut ausgebaut ist und so gut funktioniert, wie man sich das in irgendwelchen Science-Fiction-Dingern vorstellt.
Dann wäre das bestimmt cool.
Oder zum Beispiel...
Weiß ich nicht, habt ihr die Expans... Expans?
Expans?
Wie heißt denn das?
Expans.
Habt ihr die erste Staffel gesehen, zufälligerweise?
Ich hab da nicht weiter geguckt.
Ich hab nur die ersten zwei Staffeln geguckt.
In der ersten Staffel gibt es eine...
Auf irgendeinem Jupiter...
Auf irgendeinem Saturn-Mond, glaube ich.
Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt ein paar Szenen in der ersten Staffel, die spielen, glaube ich, auf irgendeiner Raumstation auf irgendeinem Saturn-Mond oder so.
Und das sind so Dinger...
Ja, wenn der Kram so gut wie in irgendwelchen Science-Fiction-Dingern funktioniert, dann wäre das bestimmt cool.
Das Problem ist nur, dass wir da halt noch gar nichts haben.
Und dort jetzt zu sein...
Alles andere als cool wäre.
Was könnte mehr Le-Epic-Reddit-420-Geon-Reefs sein als das?
Was?
Aber was ist nur eine Mars-Kolonie?
Na gut, es ist eine Kolonie...
Auf Mars.
Wille...
Okay, das Video ist, glaube ich, dumm.
Das ist der Grund, warum SpaceX im ersten Moment existiert.
Und sie arbeiten schon daran.
Das Errichtung der Kolonie, zusammen mit einer Lune-Base, ist für 2022 vorgesehen.
Ähm, by the way, Luna-Base, das ist ja auch das Geile.
Die Amis haben ja vor ein paar Jahren angekündigt, sie wollen wieder zum Mond fliegen und irgendwann dann in Zukunft auch eine Mond-Basis errichten und sonst was.
Und das sollte, glaube ich, alles schon losgehen.
Aber bis jetzt gibt es, glaube ich, noch nicht mal die fertige Rakete, womit man überhaupt zum Mond kommen würde.
Also, das haben wir schon mal besser hingekriegt, tatsächlich.
... in 2017.
Nach fünf Jahren fieberiger Arbeit.
Das Projekt ist bereits in der Stage der CGI-Renderung.
Die Kolonie wird cool...
Okay, das...
Das ist ein guter Witz gewesen.
... die ganze Fläche machen.
Mehrere Jahre harte Arbeit und wir haben schon CGI-Renders.
... eine Menge Solar-Panel und ein remote-kontrolliertes Selbst-Destruktion-Mechanismus, in dem Fall, dass Kolonien versuchen, sich zu ünionisieren.
Bleiben Sie mit uns auf dieser erstaunlichen Suizid-Mission, die keine praktischen Ziele oder Justifikationen außer der Regelung über Mars hat.
Ja, eine Mars-Kolonie ist extrem dumm und gefährlich.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass...
Also, ich meine, es ist schon eine riesen Herausforderung überhaupt, zu Mars zu kommen und dort lebend zu landen.
Aber ich glaube, dass dieser Teil noch das einfachste ist.
... und es wird für den vorgesehenen Zukunft sein.
Was dunkle Seite... Ich habe jetzt nicht genau zugehört.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall keine dunkle Seite vom Mond.
Das ist richtig.
Es gibt nur die Seite vom Mond, die wir nicht sehen.
Aber die ist nicht dunkel.
Da scheint genauso die Sonne drauf.
Ich bin hier, um zu erklären, warum.
Wenn Sie über die Mars-Kolonie aufgeregt sind, sind die Chancen, dass es Elon Musk ist.
Leute wie Elon Musk, der Millionen von Dollar bezahlt hat, um sich als realer Tony Stark zu verkaufen, haben es geschafft, viele Leute zu überzeugen, dass...
Nein, ich glaube, das Video ist blöd.
Aber eine Sache noch.
Nein, ganz ehrlich.
Über so Sachen wie Mars-Kolonie und sonst was.
Ich glaube, gerade Leute, die in meinem Alter sind oder sogar noch ein bisschen älter, denken da nicht wegen Elon Musk drüber nach.
Bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so.
Ich meine, ich bin 1984 geboren.
Da war die ganze Geschichte mit der Mondlandung noch nicht so lange her.
Ich meine, die Mondlandung war irgendwie 1970.
Nein, 1969 oder so.
1969.
Die war ein Jahr, bevor sie offiziell fertig sein wollten.
Also sprich, das war, sagen wir mal, nur 14 Jahre vor meiner Geburt.
Und dementsprechend war diese ganze Geschichte mit...
Ähm...
Die Menschheit baut demnächst Raumschiffe und fliegt zu anderen Planeten.
Und so war in meiner Jugend tatsächlich noch relativ präsent.
Und nachdem ich...
Ja, solange ich denken kann, schon ein bisschen so auf Science-Fiction-Sachen stehe.
Ich habe mir schon früh immer Gedanken gemacht, wäre es nicht cool, wenn es irgendwie eine Raumstation gäbe oder so.
Da brauche ich Elon Musk nicht dazu.
Praktikabel ist es zumindest aktuell doch nicht.
Trotzdem nicht.
Ja.
Ich bin der Meinung, wir werden das erst hinbekommen, wenn wir es überhaupt jemals hinbekommen,
wenn wir es irgendwann mal schaffen sollten,
dass ein nicht unerheblicher Teil der Menschheit an einem Strang zieht.
Also ich denke nicht, dass wir wirklich, so nach dem Motto, diese futuristischen Gedanken,
die Menschheit besiedelt, das Sonnensystem und sowas,
dass wir das schaffen werden...
Also das werden wir nicht schaffen,
von einem Unternehmen oder von einem Land.
Das werden wir nur schaffen, wenn wirklich ein Großteil der Leute zusammenarbeitet.
Du wirst es nie schaffen, dass die gesamte Menschheit an einem Strang zieht.
Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt relativ sicher, dass das nie passieren wird.
Du hast immer ein paar Leute, die können das nicht ab und müssen Stress machen.
Aber ein Großteil, ja.
Oder zumindest mehr als jetzt ein Land oder wie es jetzt teilweise mit SpaceX ist oder sowas wie eine Firma.
Dann können wir uns über sowas vielleicht Gedanken machen.
Und das sieht aktuell eher nicht so aus.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
What really happens when you spill water in an outlet?
Hm.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Kokona-Steckern passiert.
Wahrscheinlich fackelt das Holzhaus ab.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, wahrscheinlich passiert nicht sonderlich viel.
Wahrscheinlich fliegt die Sicherung raus oder sowas.
Mal gucken.
So designed to protect you from getting an electrical shock if they're exposed to water.
But what would happen if you didn't have one of these outlets and you say you got water inside?
Well, that's exactly what one of my viewers asked me.
So I decided to put it to the test to find out what would happen if a regular outlet was exposed to water.
And the tests you'll see in this video are pretty extreme and I was blown away by the...
Der Toaster?
...the results.
And do not try any of the tests that I did in this video...
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, die Sicherung fliegt raus.
Aber anscheinend geht es jetzt ja darum, wenn die Sicherung nicht rausfliegt.
Vielleicht wird's warm.
...all of them are hazardous, you could die, and electricity and water do not mix.
And even though you can't see it on the video...
Don't try... Okay, da siehst du gleich, wo das Video hergestellt wurde.
Es sollte, glaube ich, jedem klar sein, dass man es nicht daheim ausprobiert, eine Steckdose in die Badewanne zu schmeißen.
Aber bei den Amis ist das nicht so.
...make sure that I was safe the entire time.
Da wirst du...
Die verklagen den Videohersteller noch.
Weil sie fast gestorben wären, weil sie es ausprobiert haben.
...because I don't recommend that anyone try any of these tests themselves.
For my first test, I connected an extension cord into a regular outlet with no GFCI protection.
Then I plugged in this power strip, and I added the eggbeater so that you could tell the power was on, and started to spray it.
And even though I missed the first couple of shots, I finally started to get the water right into the outlets, but nothing happened.
Ja, da ist ja auch nichts verbunden!
Nur weil da Wasser reindingst...
Also, aktuell ist das ja...
Die Löcher sind ja immer noch...
Okay, es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass sich das im Outlet verteilt und es dann da kurz schließt.
...this test was gonna end pretty quick, and the breaker would in fact trip.
And then I really started to spray that thing, and there was no change at all in the eggbeater, and the circuit breaker never tripped.
I really couldn't believe it at this point, so I decided to take this test a step further, and I filled up a container with water, grabbed that power strip, and dropped it right in.
Now first nothing changed at all, but you can see that the strip kind of got hung up on the side, so I gave it a push, and now the thing was completely submerged.
Also, eins ist schon mal klar. Wenn was ist, dieser Handschuh wird ihn nicht schützen vor irgendwas.
...submerged.
How is this possible? This is completely nuts, that the eggbeater is still running, the power strip is fine, in fact you can even see the lights on the strip working just fine underneath the water.
And one thing did go wrong.
I got a FedEx delivery right in the middle of this experiment, so I had to disconnect everything to grab the package.
And once they left, I plugged everything back in, and there were no problems at all.
Eggbeater's running, power strip is on, and everything's good.
After the test was over, I started thinking, maybe I need to get something bigger underneath the water.
...the water that would actually trip that circuit breaker sooner.
So I grabbed a fishtank, filled it up full of water, along with this simple plug-in light.
Now that isn't an LED, it's just a light.
It's a regular 100 watt incandescent bulb, and you can see it works just fine out of the water.
And once I submerge it, nothing changes at all, the bulb is still working just fine.
But the bulb is also acting kind of like a life preserver, so I needed to weight it down.
So I grabbed a brick, and I put it on top of the power strip.
Das ist ja auch ein geiles Kokona-Experiment hier.
...so that it would be completely submerged.
And you can see that there was still no change in the light at all.
In fact, it looks better under the water than it does outside.
Chat, ist das jetzt erwartet oder unerwartet, was man hier sieht?
Ich kann da grad mein Head nicht around-wrappen.
...why that bulb looks different like?
Der Versuchsaufbau sieht auf jeden Fall ein bisschen gefährlich aus, mit seinem komischen Ofen-Handschuh.
...some type of optical illusion.
At this point, I'm completely blown away.
How is this stuff working fine underwater without any problems at all?
So now we're gonna do the final test.
Ah, jetzt wird das Wasser ein bisschen aufgeheizt.
Dann nimm mal das scheiß Toastboot raus, das erfüllt keinen Sinn.
...which is a pretty strange feeling.
And then I went ahead and connected the whole thing back up.
And of course everything's working great, why wouldn't it work underwater?
...the toaster is still not on, and that's the key.
So to turn it on, I need to push that plunger down.
I'm certainly not gonna put my hand on the tank.
So using this piece of plastic lumber, I was able to engage that plunger to get the toaster to turn on.
I had no idea what was gonna happen, because that toaster uses 1200 watts of power.
But as you can see, the little bubbles coming out tell me those heating elements are actually on.
And then finally, after about 10 minutes, this is what happened.
This is absolutely ridiculous. I almost couldn't believe what I had seen, so I repeated the same test,
but this time I'm gonna use a GFCI-protected outlet.
I poured just a small amount of water into the strip,
and within just a few seconds the breaker tripped and did its job.
So after I finished all these tests, I learned one thing,
and that's that GFCI outlets definitely work, and they will protect you against any kind of electrocution
when you're around water and electricity.
Das ist aber auch eine ziemliche Kokonasicherung, oder?
Was ist denn die da so lange für braucht?
The most important takeaway is that you have no protection at all using a regular outlet
if you should get any water in it or around it.
So I highly recommend always following your electric codes
and using GFCI outlets in any location that might get wet or be exposed to any kind of moisture.
And remember that even though those appliances worked under water, that water was fully electrified,
and if anybody put their hand in it, they would be electrocuted and likely die.
So hopefully you enjoyed this video. If you did, please give me a thumbs up
and subscribe to my channel for more videos coming up.
And I will see you in the next video. Bye!
Ich muss allerdings auch sagen, so billig ist es gar nicht mehr, seitdem ich euch für eure Einsendungen bezahle.
Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Los geht's mit Christian.
Easy money.
Der hat sich ein Thema angenommen, das mir auch irgendwann ins Haus steht.
Was machen wir mit den Kinderzimmern?
Welche Werkzeuge geben wir den Kindern zur Haussteuerung an die Hand?
Welche Kinder?
Ich werde alles dafür tun, dass ich in nächster Zeit mich um diese Frage nicht kümmern muss.
Ich würde dir noch eben nahelegen, deine Sprachzylinder oder hier Kugeln oder so stumm zu schalten, taub zu schalten.
Nein.
Ja, ihr wisst schon.
Ich werde das nicht aus allen Videos rauspiepsen.
Gerade wenn ihr nicht zu sehen seid, kann man dem Ganzen dann besser folgen.
Nur damit ihr gewarnt seid.
Aber jetzt mal sehen, wie Christian das gelöst hat.
Ich wollte dir mal ein Beispiel zeigen, wie ich verschiedene Automationen...
Bobo der Siebenschläfer.
...zugänglich gemacht habe hier für unsere viereinhalbjährige Tochter.
Und zwar mittels eines Android-Tablets, auf dem...
Ich bin ja direkt getriggert.
...irgendeinen Kiosk-Browser oder so.
Gut.
Der auf dem Kopf stehende Huawei-Schriftzug.
Da kannst du gleich anfangen, Geld für einen Therapeuten für deine Kinder...
Naja, das Ding steht auf dem Kopf, weil der USB-Anschluss an der Stelle ist.
Naja, komm.
Leute, die Steckdose ist da.
Das muss doch so sein.
Die Steckdose ist irgendwo rechts und der USB-Anschluss ist da.
Was soll er denn machen?
Soll er es hier unten rumlegen?
Einfach nur, dass der Schriftzug richtig krumm ist.
...beiseite zu liegen.
Nee, mich triggert das nicht.
...um...
Kannst ja abkleben.
...assistent im Kiosk-Mode läuft.
Finde ich nicht schlimm.
Das heißt, es geht automatisch dann an, wenn entsprechende Bewegungen erkannt werden.
Ja.
Was hiermit verknüpft ist, ist beispielsweise, dass unsere Tochter entweder Rollläden hoch- und runterfahren kann
oder entsprechend auf...
Finde ich gut.
...vorselektierte Kinderhütte...
Ja, also sprich, wenn die Tochter Bobo der Siebenschläfer hören will, dann klickt sie das abends an.
Dann läuft Bobo der Siebenschläfer.
Richtig gute Idee.
Finde ich nice.
...greifen kann.
Die dann...
Das ist nicht Papa, lies mir mal was vor oder so oder Mama, lies mir mal was vor.
Da ist Mama, ho ab, ich will jetzt Bobo der Siebenschläfer hören auf dem Tablet.
Finde ich...
Finde ich gut.
So was hat...
Der Chat sagt, so was hat in einem Kinderzimmer nichts verloren.
Warum nicht?
Es ist das Jahr 2022 und die Tochter ist vier Jahre.
Da ist das ein bisschen Technik an sich doch jetzt nicht verkehrt.
Warum nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als ist das...
Als sendet das irgendwie gefährliche Strahlung aus oder so.
Also ich meine, es kann ja legit nichts passieren, wenn das Tablet da hängt.
Ich meine, ob sie jetzt...
Guck mal, ich habe früher Bobo der Siebenschläfer...
Ich habe nicht Bobo der Siebenschläfer.
Aber ich habe früher...
Ich hätte früher Bobo der Siebenschläfer von Kassette gehört und die hört Bobo der
Siebenschläfer vom Tablet.
Wo ist denn jetzt da der Unterschied?
Tja...
Okay, Alexa Lautsprecher wäre es bei mir definitiv nicht.
... Raum steht über die entsprechende Spotify Playlist.
Soll das Kind wie du werden?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Habe ich auch keine Kinder.
Ich will nicht, dass meine Kinder wie ich werden.
Dahinter sind überall Automationen hinterlegt, wie auch...
Kamera...
Ja, ich persönlich würde die Kamera wahrscheinlich abkleben.
Die Sache ist nur die, du brauchst die Kamera in dem Fall, dass du die Bewegung erkennen
kannst.
Also das Display ist ja aus und erst wenn einer davor ist und reinguckt in das Display,
geht das an.
Das heißt, in dem Fall braucht man die Kamera.
Und da würde ich mir tatsächlich gar nicht so viele Gedanken machen, wenn es jetzt nicht
gerade ein Amazon Fire Tablet ist mit Zugang zum Internet, beziehungsweise ohne Deep Loaded,
dann ist das wahrscheinlich alles in Ordnung.
... die Leselampe, die sich ansteuern lässt oder auch die Automation zum ins Bett gehen.
Das heißt, hier startet dann entsprechend auch eine Automation, bei der einerseits die
Rollläden...
Okay, das finde ich ein bisschen cringe, wenn Alexa zu meinem Kind sagt, ich wünsche dir
gute Nacht.
... andererseits aber auch ein kleines Nachtlicht angeht, sowie auch Lichter über dem Bett.
Schon ein cooles Kinderzimmer.
... die sich dann...
Ja.
... nach drei Minuten jedoch abdimmen und ausgehen, sodass eigentlich nur noch das Nachtlicht
an ist.
Ja, wie gesagt, cooles Kinderzimmer und auf jeden Fall nette Automation.
Das mit den Hörbüchern ist tatsächlich eine Option, wenn wir irgendwann aus der Auswahl
der Tony Box rausgewachsen sind.
Ich meine, ich bin wirklich überzeugt, guckt ihr jetzt aber nicht.
Aber ich habe bei euch auch eine rumstehen sehen.
Bringt mich auf jeden Fall auf Ideen.
Und Home Assistant ist hier im Haus in den letzten Wochen, Monaten tatsächlich auch
ein Thema gewesen.
Ja.
Ich glaube, wenn ich das Tablet andersrum und dann irgendwas für die Kabelführung überlegen
würde, wäre mein Hauptkritikpunkt...
Aber ne, sehr schön.
Kommen wir jetzt zu etwas völlig...
Sein Hauptkritikpunkt oder weil seine Frau sonst meckert?
... anderem.
Nämlich hat Julian...
Das Interface...
Ihr habt recht, Chat.
Ihr habt recht.
Ich lag falsch.
Gui.
Lull Grinch, Alter.
Mit vier Jahren Arch Linux CLI sein Hörbuch starten.
Ein Gui, wo man draufklicken kann.
Ja?
Die muss draufklicken.
T-Max aufmachen, Control-B, Control-C, neues Tab, VLC, Bobo der Siebenschläfer.mkv.
Ja, klar, klar, natürlich.
Ihr habt recht.
Also einfach ein Gui, wo man draufklicken kann.
Das ist tatsächlich cringe.
Das stimmt.
Das geht so nicht.
Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie sowas aussieht.
Wir hatten hier ein kleines Fuchsproblem, wie man sieht.
Bei der alten Hühnerhütte wurde tatsächlich übernacht...
Bestimmt ein Firefox.
Ha!
... das Brett rausgezapft.
Das Brett wurde ausgerissen und der Fuchs konnte in den Hühnerstall einbrechen.
Um das zu verhindern, haben wir einen neuen Hühnerstall gebaut.
Meine Frau meinte, wäre ja ganz schön, wenn der neue Hühnerstall Strom hätte.
Dann dachte ich mir, okay, wenn wir eh ein Erdkabel ziehen müssen, dann können wir
da auch völlig ausflippen und da mal Smart Home integrieren, wie neu.
Das ist der absolut richtige und einzig logische Schritt.
Einzig logischer Schritt, genau.
Um die ein bisschen sicherer zu machen.
Hier vorne haben wir die neue Hütte.
Folgende Maßen.
Die ist hier 20 Zentimeter.
Ist das Außengehege hier eingebuddelt.
Komplett rundherum betoniert.
Dann haben wir hier...
Ist das der Hühnerstall?
Das ist, glaube ich, der erste smart gesteuerte Elektrozaun, den ich gesehen habe.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, also ich habe keine Hühner, aber hier in der Nachbarschaft gibt
es ein paar Leute mit Hühner und ab und zu im Sommer war ich da auch schon mal drüben
und habe die Hühner gefüttert.
Und die laufen einfach ohne Zaun den ganzen Tag durch den Garten.
Das juckt die nicht.
Also die Hühner rennen da über das ganze Grundstück.
Da passiert nichts.
Was halt auch über eine Acara Steckdose...
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, muss es ein Elektrozaun sein?
Das Ding ist doch eh komplett zu.
Eine Ringkamera mit Battery Pack.
Noch aktuell müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir da noch so ein Solarpanel dran machen.
Je nachdem, wie lange so ein Akku davon hält.
Dann haben wir hier vorne die zwei Lüfter, die ich hier eingebaut habe.
Die werden auch über eine Acara...
Ah, gute.
Arctic Cooling oder was ist das für Lüfter?
Eine Acara Steckdose, gesteuert.
Zeige ich euch gleich noch von innen.
Hier vorne haben wir...
Da war ein Huhn.
Ich habe es gesehen.
Leute, hier war es.
Guckt mal da rechts.
Da ist das Huhn.
Hier.
Da, da ist es.
Hier vorne haben wir...
Ne, das sind Katzen.
Das ist ein Katzenschwanz gewesen eher.
Da ist eine Katze dahinter.
Mehr Elektrodraht.
Oder?
Hier unten einmal komplett die Litze gespannt.
Man sieht es nicht richtig.
Wie gesagt, über Nacht an, dass da auch kein Tier sich darunter einen Weg verschaffen kann.
Dann haben wir hier die Tür.
Die Tür habe ich hier mit einem Magneten gesichert, dass sie immer gut anliegt.
Also an der Tür fehlt mir jetzt noch irgendwie ein Nuki oder so.
Oder irgendwas mit einem...
Smart Lock.
...klaren Tastenfeld.
Hier vorne ist ein Acara Türsensor.
Der löst halt eben aus, wenn nachts die Tür noch offen steht oder tagsüber länger wie
eine Stunde die Tür offen ist.
Ja, kann man machen.
Dann geht der Acara Hub, schaltet dann auf ein rotes Licht und signalisiert mir dann halt,
dass die Tür noch offen steht.
Ich würde bloß lieb nehmen, den Acara Hub verwenden.
Eine Ringkamera.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Kamera, diesmal mit Strom.
Ganz normal angeschlossen.
Dann haben wir hier vorne die beiden Lüfter.
Die Lüfter gehen halt über die Acara Steckdose.
Werden die halt angesteuert über den Temperatursensor.
Das heißt, wenn wir hier über 30 Grad drin haben, gehen die beiden Lüfter an.
Ja, Freifett.
Um hier ein bisschen zu lüften, ein bisschen Hitzestau rauszukriegen.
Freifett.
Das ist nachvollziehbar.
Du willst ja wahrscheinlich Eier einsammeln und keine slow gekochten Hühner.
Wenn die Temperatur wieder unter 30 Grad fällt, dann gehen die Lüfter automatisch aus.
Dann ist hier die von meiner Frau gewünschte Lampe natürlich nicht zu verachten.
Dann haben wir hier...
Dann haben wir hier, wie gesagt, den Sensor von innen.
Und die Klappe hat auch den gleichen Türsensor.
Die zeige ich euch gleich nochmal von außen.
Mit auch normalen Steuerung, dass die Klappe automatisch auf und zu geht.
So, hier wäre nochmal die Klappe von außen.
Das ist im Prinzip die automatische Klappensteuerung.
Die hat einen Lichtsensor verbaut.
Sobald es dunkel wird, geht die Klappe zu.
Morgens geht die Klappe, wenn es hell wird, auf.
Ja, aber wer sorgt denn dafür, dass die Hühner dann auch alle drin sind?
Wenn es dunkel ist?
Dann hier unten haben wir dann einmal...
Weil ich meine, wenn ein Huhn noch draußen ist und die Klappe geht zu und dann?
Akara-Sensor, der halt eben, weil wenn die Tür geschlossen ist...
Ja, ja, die Hühner gehen selber rein.
Aber stellt euch mal vor, ein Huhn ist noch draußen, dann geht die Klappe zu.
Natural Selection.
Ja, so kann man es auch sehen.
... auch noch bei uns im Hub an.
Aber dieser kleine Magnet von dem Akara-Sensor, da so aufgeklebt, ist das Hühner sicher?
Ja.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe noch nie Hühner gehalten.
Der Akara-Hub.
Also, es ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr coole Festung, die du da gebaut hast.
Die Hühner werden weitgehend automatisch gemanagt.
Fehlt noch irgendwie, glaube ich...
Futter?
Du hast ja nach Ausbaustufen gefragt.
Ein automatischer Eierabtransport.
Futter. Automatisches Futter.
Das scheint irgendwie am Hang gelegen zu sein.
Auf jeden Fall auch dir vielen Dank für die Einsendung.
Wie alle bekommst du natürlich einen 50 Euro Amazon-Gutschein für die Mithilfe.
Genau.
Der dann für weitere Restaurationsspiele gerne genutzt wird.
Haas.
Haas. Hühner as a Service.
Kommen wir zu Marco.
Marco.
Und wie würde das für Hähne heißen?
Kaas.
Cock as a Service, oder wie?
Marco hat eine Spülmaschine geschickt.
Und da bin ich gespannt, was die ausmacht.
Sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal auffälliger aus, als die, die einfach nur so einen Punkt auf dem Boden projizieren.
Das gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut.
Weil das ja...
Wobei Cock as a Service tatsächlich auch ein bisschen zwei...
Zweideutig wäre, oder?
Wobei...
Heißt das nicht so...
Heißt das nicht Roosterhahn?
Ja.
Nicht Cock.
Cock as a Service klingt eher nach einer...
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendeiner...
Gay-Streaming...
Ähm...
Webcam-Plattform oder sowas.
So sieht man wirklich auf den ersten Blick das...
Gatschi, was?
Warum ist es da rot?
Ah, weil das fertig ist.
Ach so, Moment.
Das ist schon nachgerüstet?
Okay, das ist ziemlich cool.
Falls es wirklich praktikabler aussieht, als die fertigen Lösungen.
Mhm.
Wie hat Marco das denn gemacht?
Finde ich cool.
Wenn meine Kinder ihr Geschirr immer auf und nicht in die Spülmaschine stellen, habe ich ihnen eine...
WLED-Leiste unten drunter.
Also LED-Leiste unten drunter, per WLED, okay.
Messung, ein Fensterkontakt an der Unterseite der Tür.
Gute Idee.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Und WLED.
Streckt der Verbrauch der Maschine an.
Loading-Effekt fällt der Verbraucher unter 10 Watt.
Finde ich eine gute Idee.
Wenn die Tür länger als eine Minute offen ist, wird zu grün gewechselt.
Gesteuert wird alles mit Home Assistant.
Sehr cool.
Und weil das jetzt schon zum wiederholten Male aufkommt, will ich das kurz als Gelegenheit nutzen, um euch spontan von einem Plan von mir für den Sommer zu erzählen.
Er hat einen schönen Farbverlauf-Hintergrund.
Ist das Greenscreen oder ist das ein wirklicher Hintergrund, der beleuchtet wird?
Ich spiele aktuell mit dem Gedanken ein Home Assistant.
Ich spiele aktuell mit dem Gedanken ein Home Assistant-Einsteigerkurs im Videoformat zu machen.
Um allen, die bisher keine Lust dazu hatten oder die sich nicht getraut haben oder die gar nicht von den Möglichkeiten...
Da finde ich, das bringt nichts.
Weil gerade Home Assistant kann alles irgendwie und es ist extrem individuell, wie du es machen willst.
Beziehungsweise was du da genau machen willst.
Ich meine klar, die Basics, wie installiere ich ein Add-on oder wie schalte ich eine Integration an oder so, das kann man machen.
Aber das ist auch wirklich, das hat man schnell drin.
Das eigentliche Hirnschmalz in Home Assistant fließt da rein.
Wie macht man das für sich, also sprich, wie macht man das in seinem eigenen System, dass da was Sinnvolles bei rauskommt?
Weil die Leute haben auch total unterschiedliche Anforderungen.
Der eine will Status lieber beim Öffnen, der andere lieber, wenn es geschlossen wird.
Der nächste sagt, ja, aber die Temperatur da.
Und das muss dann anders sein.
Und wenn ich dann die Treppe runterlaufe, will ich, dass es getriggert wird.
Also das ist komplett individuell.
...Würsten, die ein echtes Smart Home bieten kann, um denen einen Startpunkt zu geben.
Und ich glaube, das muss so ein bisschen außerhalb dieses Kanals stattfinden, jedenfalls in der Tiefe.
Weil das einfach zu speziell wird und nicht jeden Zuschauer hier interessieren wird.
Und das Ganze wird auch was kosten müssen, weil ich auch noch plane, Hilfe dazu zu holen.
Weil ich das sonst zeitlich gar nicht schaffe.
Und weil ich glaube, dass es das inhaltlich besser machen wird.
Aber wenn du interessiert bist, dann gehe auf, muss ich mir nochmal schnell ausdenken bis zum Video, spielundzeug.com slash ha.
Und trag dich da in die Warteliste ein, um dann, wenn es dazu kommt und wenn es soweit ist, direkt zum Vorzugspreis durchstarten zu können.
Gut.
Genug abgeschwiffen, abgeschweift.
Patrick hat mir einen Monitorlift geschickt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was ein Monitorlift ist.
Wahrscheinlich passend zum höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Ich möchte heute mal wieder eine meiner Automationen vorstellen.
Und zwar habe ich aus einem alten Schrank etwas für unser Schlafzimmer gebaut.
Alexa, schalte Monitorlift an.
Da hört es bei mir schon auf, wenn man das über Alexa triggert.
Ich bin ja überhaupt kein Voice Assistant Fan.
Das finden wir so aus.
Oh.
Quietsch, quietsch, quietsch.
Ah.
Dass man Fernseh gucken kann.
Das ist ein Monitorlift.
Wie gesagt, habe ich das...
Coole Sache.
Einziges Problem, was ich dabei sehe.
Wenn der Fernseher einfach normal dastehen würde, braucht er wahrscheinlich eine ganze Ecke weniger Platz als mit dieser Konstruktion.
Das Ganze aus einem alten Schrank gebaut.
Für den Lift habe ich einen Jalousienmotor verwendet.
Die Elektronik habe ich per...
Das sieht aber ganz schön...
Ich meine, es gibt ihm recht, dass es funktioniert.
Das sieht aber schon ein bisschen krass gebastelt aus.
Aber coole Konstruktion.
Ich wäre wahrscheinlich nicht drauf gekommen, aber...
Für den Lift habe ich einen Jalousienmotor verwendet.
Die Elektronik habe ich per Sonoff gelöst.
Das Ganze wird über IO...
Also, man sieht auf jeden Fall, der hat definitiv so Sachen schon öfters gemacht.
Ich wüsste beispielsweise an der Stelle gar nicht, welchen Motor ich dafür verwende, beziehungsweise wie ich den ansteuere und sowas.
Ja, was es bringt, bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher.
Weil, wie gesagt, das ganze Ding hier braucht mehr Platz als der Fernseher an sich.
Und man könnte, wenn man sowas hier hat, könnte man den Fernseher einfach oben drauf stellen und es unten als Storage verwenden für irgendwas.
Aber...
Ja...
Ich meine, cool ist es, ja.
Ansonsten verdeckt er das Fenster.
Hm...
Ja, aber das macht...
Glaube ich nicht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall cool, weil es geht.
Genau.
Die Idee ist cool, wie... sinnvoll weiß ich nicht so genau.
Ja, und das war es auch schon.
Coole Idee, Patrick.
Ey, man hätte ja auch den Fernseher an die Decke hochkurbeln können und dann einfach nur runter lassen abends.
Dann würde er dann hier hängen.
Ja, und das war es auch schon.
Coole Idee, Patrick.
Ich mag, dass du einen alten Schrank dafür missbraucht hast.
Oder Upcycling, wie man heute sagt.
Upcycling.
Einziger Kritikpunkt wäre, also neben dem Tropfen Öl, der da irgendwo vielleicht rein muss, sind die Sprachbefehle.
Alexa, hol den Fernseher raus und pack ihn wieder weg oder so, fände ich ein bisschen organischer als Monitorlift an und aus.
Aber am Ende ändert es nichts.
Ich würde es gar nicht mit Alexa machen.
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich über das Handy steuern oder irgendwie anders mal gucken, ob man das beispielsweise automatisieren könnte mit einem Drucksensor im Bett oder so.
Aber ich bin, wie gesagt, ihr wisst, ich bin kein Voice-Assistant-Fan.
Wenn man einen Fernseher am Bett haben möchte.
Habt ihr einen Fernseher im Schlafzimmer?
Schreibt das gerne mal unten in die Kommentare, um hier einen Disput, einen Schlusspunkt zu verpassen.
Dann berichtet Tobias von seinem Smart Home als Musikproduzent.
Was auch immer das bedeutet, schauen wir rein.
Hey, ich bin Tobi.
Hauptberuflich bin ich Softwareentwickler und nebenberuflich Musikproduzent und DJ.
In meinem Smart Home bin ich Musikproduzent und DJ.
In meinem Smart Home auf circa 40 Quadratmetern mit vier Räumen habe ich insgesamt für...
Das ist schon auf jeden Fall ein ganz cooles Setup.
Da ist ordentlich was, ja.
Einzelne schaltbare Steckdosen, Bewegungsmelder, Tür- und Fenstersensoren, smarte Heizkörber, Thermostate und so weiter.
Aber das hat ja fast jedes Smart Home mittlerweile.
Daher möchte ich in diesem Video auf eine ganz besondere Anbindung eingehen, die sonst kaum ein Smart Home hat.
Und zwar mein Netzwerk-Audio-Interface.
Ich habe über meine...
Ein Netzwerk-Audio-Interface?
Ja, klar.
Okay.
So was gibt es, klar.
Und mehrere Soundquellen, die alle an diesem einen zentralen Netzwerk-Audio-Interface hängen.
Ah, das ist quasi Audio-Netzwerk fürs Haus.
Und zwar, das ist ein Moto 828 ES.
Ich habe auch ein Moto-Audio-Interface, aber kein Netzwerk-Interface.
An dem Audio-Interface hängen zum Beispiel mein Desktop-Rechner mit der Audio-Workstation, mein DJ-Setup, mein E-Piano...
Warum hat er...
Der hat da oben sogar irgendwelche...
Der macht doch Livestreams, oder?
Der hat hier oben seine Kamera und Beleuchtungsgedöns.
Nur mal, um die Stereo-Quellen zu nennen.
Dann kommen dazu noch zwei Mikrofoneingänge.
Alter, was für ein krasses Setup.
Aber hat das keine Verzögerung, wenn du es über das Netzwerk machst?
Also, wenn dein Computer-Audio durch ein Audio-Interface im Netzwerk...
Kommt drauf an.
Kommt drauf an, wie es gemacht ist.
Also, ich denke mal, dass die Verzögerung nicht spürbar ist.
Weil ich meine, im Prinzip...
Verzögerung übers normales Audio...
Du hast ja auch eine Übertragungszeit, die du übers Audio-Kabel hast.
Aber das ist halt nahezu Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Über das Netzwerk-Kabel ist es dann wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie encoded.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das großartig Verzögerungen macht.
Vor allem halt auch, weil das Profi-Equipment ist.
Ja, die Tastatur ist halt...
Ja, beste, beste Sache ist auf jeden Fall, weil ein Trackpoint drauf ist.
Irgendwas wird doch da direkt verkabelt sein, oder?
Die kann ich dann auf zwei Paar Stereo-Lautsprecher in meinem Schreibtisch routen...
Der Lenovo-Nippel, genau.
...ein direkt angeschlossener Kopfhörer, eine Soundbar an meinem Fernseher oder einen Lautsprecher in meinem Schlafzimmer.
Darüber bin ich extrem flexibel, was das Routing von Audio angeht.
Zum Beispiel kann ich, wenn ich einen Film von meinem Desktop...
Companion habe ich hier normalerweise auch, wenn der Rechner nicht aus ist.
Oder die Software.
...Rechner auf meinem Fernsehschauer in Ausgang auf die Soundbar geben.
Oder ich kann Musik anmachen, welche dann zum Beispiel in meinem Schlafzimmer zu hören ist.
Oder ich kann einfach Musik überall auf allen Lautsprechern anmachen, wenn ich zum Beispiel Freunde da habe und wir eine kleine Feier machen.
Das Ganze hat aber noch nicht viel mit Automation zu tun.
Welche Automation habe ich dazu denn eigentlich?
Und zwar, die interessanten Automationen sind eigentlich zwei Stück.
Einmal kann ich zwischen 22 Uhr und 8 Uhr den Bass abdrehen, also im Equalizer den Basskanal senken.
Ja, klingt sinnvoll.
Das ist die eine Automation.
Und die andere Automation ist das, wenn ich als Soundquelle zum Beispiel den Apple TV verwende,
dann wird ein Audiokompressor aktiviert, der das Audio ein wenig zusammendrückt,
das dafür sorgt, dass die lauten Töne ähnlich laut sind wie die mittellauten Töne,
was den Effekt hat, dass zum Beispiel bei Filmen Sprache und Effekte...
Das ist gut.
...Explosionen zum Beispiel...
Das ist gut. Ich finde die Abmischung bei vielen Filmen auch Pantschamp.
...gleich laut sind und ich nicht mit lauten Explosionen meine Nachbarn störe, währenddessen ich von dem Dialog gewöhnt werde.
Ahnung, was du da genau machst. Also klar, die
Automation, die du gezeigt hast,
das ist mehr
oder weniger das, was Sonos ja auch als Night
Mode zum Beispiel in der Soundbar eingebaut
hat.
Aber du hast es einfach für deine ganze Wohnung, für alles,
was da akustisch abläuft. Das ist schon sehr cool.
Und auch irgendwie so ein
Schalter in HomeKit zu haben, um
den Bass runterzuschalten.
Ja, coole Sache. Ich liebe ja solche
Einblicke, genau wie den Hühnerstall
eben. Einfach Sachen, die ich sonst
nirgendwo gesehen hätte.
Der Chat listet einfach
alle Hersteller gerade auf. Ja, von irgendeinem
Hersteller wird das sein. Vielleicht war es auch
ein Netgear-Switch.
Nein.
Ist es trotzdem cool? Allerdings.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob man Sonos
empfehlen kann.
Und das im Detail nochmal
angucken oder sehen, was er so mit diesem Setup
treibt. Also ich kann euch nur
sagen, es war definitiv keine Fritzbox.
Eine normale Eingangstür
wäre langweilig, heißt das Video.
Ich sehe Kabel, Kabelkanäle,
ich sehe einen Nuki, ich sehe irgendeinen Boxer.
Moment, hat der am Türspion
eine Kamera?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Zunächst einmal sieht man hier unten einen Nuki.
Würde ich nie machen.
Ich bin überhaupt kein Fan. Es gibt zwei Sachen,
die mag ich nicht, was Heimautomatisierung
angeht. Das sind Voice Assistants
und das sind
smarte Schlösser.
Das Powerpack zugekauft
habe. Und damit ich
das Powerpack nicht immer
wieder mal alle Jubiläare laden muss.
Warum blinkt das eigentlich die ganze Zeit, das Ding?
Mit einem USB-C-Kabel, was dann hier
über einen Kabelkanal nach oben geht
und hier oben an einen
Türkontakt geht. Das Ganze
mit Strom belegt.
Wenn man das Ganze aufmacht, sieht man,
dass das einfach nur
sind die Batterienkontakte.
Ach, der lädt das dann da drüber.
Okay, six head time, Alter.
Das heißt, wenn die Tür geschlossen ist,
ist da Strom drauf und
dann lädt das...
Ah, high feather time.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das war auch das allererste, was ich mit dieser Tür
tatsächlich getan habe.
Die Klingel, oder?
Sieht man, dass da oben ein Spiel
Technik sich hinter verbirgt und keine
klassische Klingel mehr. Am Ende habe ich hier
einen Gleichrichter gebaut und ein Relais.
Ein Full Bridge Rectifier.
Wenn die Klingel klingelt, dann
schaltet das Relais und
am Pi geht über einen Plugin.
Homebridge, was ich selber geschrieben habe.
Dann auf meinem iPhone in HomeKit
die Türklingel an. Oder ehemals
reiner klassischer Türspion.
Hierhinter verbirgt sich jetzt ein kleiner
ESP32 mit Kamera.
Gute Idee.
Habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht dran gedacht,
dass man damit ja auch einen Türspion
Film aufnehmen könnte.
Gute Idee.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ist das legal,
wenn du nicht aufnimmst?
Wenn du nicht aufnimmst,
warum nicht?
Als hier oben über den Türkontakt
mit Strom versorgt, heißt natürlich, wenn die Tür
offen ist, ist der aus, aber das stört mich nicht.
Mal ganz einfach abgesehen, das muss ja erstmal einer mitbekommen.
Wenn ich jetzt klingel, dann
klingelt nicht mehr hier oben die Klingel,
sondern es klingeln meine Homepods, es klingelt
auf meinem Telefon und
ich kriege das Videobild der
kleinen Karte des ESP angezeigt.
Coole Sache.
Ich will das Videobild sehen. Zeig es mir, das Video ist gleich vorbei.
Zeigst du den Spion?
Der Spion etwa nicht? Die Kamera?
Wie das aussieht, zeige ich euch jetzt einmal.
Okay, dankeschön.
Was?
Alter!
Was zum?
Ist das ein Cowboy?
Damit könnte ich jetzt wenig anfangen,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Das ist einfach nur ein Flurschrank
oder so eine Linie, die hinter dem Kopf läuft.
Ja, sehr cool. Auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Upgrade
der Wohnungstür. Mit den Kontakten finde ich ganz spannend.
Also ich meine, da du sowieso Kabelkanäle
auf der Tür hast, hättest du es natürlich auch
zur anderen Seite legen können.
Aber hey, es ist
auf jeden Fall technisch sehr cool.
Mario hat Kurzbefehle Arbeitszeit geschickt.
Ich habe die App ein bisschen gezockt und bin dabei
komplett ausgerastet und ich würde es gerne
mit euch teilen, weil ich quasi eine Möglichkeit
gefunden habe, wie ich Variablen
abspeichern kann und sie in einem weiteren
Kurzbefehl dann wieder verwenden kann.
Kurz als Hintergrund. Ich arbeite im Neben- und
Job als Fahrer und kann daher nie
sagen, also ich habe keinen Schichtplan, sondern
ich kriege am Tag vorher Bescheid, wann ich zum
Arbeiten beginnen muss. Bei einer
Veranstaltung, wo sehr viele Fahrer gebucht sind,
müssen wir abends dann noch eine Stunden-E-Mail
schreiben quasi, wo drin steht, wie lange wir
gearbeitet haben. Wenn ich jetzt hier nach links
rüberwische, kann ich einstempeln.
Da gebe ich dann an, wann ich zu arbeiten beginne.
Nehmen wir jetzt zum Beispiel um 10 Uhr.
Dann gebe ich noch ein, wo ich zum
Arbeiten beginne und drücke dann anschließend
auf fertig.
Somit erstellt sich ein Kalenderereignis
mit 10 Stunden.
Können wir hier mal noch gucken. Da steht jetzt
soweit nichts drin. Kann ich eben hier
auf das Tanken-Shortcut drücken.
Dann gebe ich eben die Tankart an, intern
oder extern, was ich tanke,
wie viel Strom und
wie viel Strom. Das läuft jetzt durch.
Dann kann ich noch anklicken, ob ich eine E-Mail benutze
oder nicht. Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es
gecheckt. Wenn ich jetzt mal das Kalenderereignis
anschaue, sehe ich in den Notizen eben
über diese Shortcuts-App,
die nicht mal Shortcut heißt.
Nee, Workflow hieße früher, Shortcuts
heißt sie jetzt.
Eben ausstempeln
und dann gebe ich eben ein, wann mein
Feierabend ist. In dem Fall 17.30 Uhr.
Danach gebe ich eben noch
meine Anfangskilometer
vom Auto an.
Danach noch die jetzigen Kilometer
vom Arbeitstag.
Dann gebe ich an,
wie oft ich gewartet habe.
Okay, da würde ich jetzt nicht so unbedingt unter Heimautomatisierung...
Du bist Fahrer, also offenbar kein Taxi.
Sonst würde das ja irgendwie...
Vieles automatisch erfassen.
Und du wäschst dein Auto dreimal
während einer Schicht? Was machst du?
Ist das irgendein edles Chauffeur-Dienst?
Was ich ausgelegt habe und wie ich
oft beim Flughafen war, eben die Sachen,
die relevant sind.
Wie viel Geld du ausgelegt hast?
Was ist das? Geheimdienst?
Moskau im Kassel? Warum hast du
einen Kalendereintrag für morgen, wo einfach
nur Fliegen drinsteht?
Das ist alles
sehr dubios.
Für die Abrechnung und ob ich eine Stunde
E-Mail benötige.
Dann sehe ich wieder im Kalenderereignis,
dass jetzt alles in Notizen eingefügt worden
ist und mein Arbeitstag beendet ist.
Zusätzlich habe ich aber auch noch Notizen
erstellt, eben mit den gefahrenen Kilometern,
was ich getankt habe, wie viel auf dich gewaschen
habe und wie viel Bargeld ich ausgelegt habe,
sodass ich die jetzt anschließend in dem Shortcut,
um die E-Mail zu schreiben, automatisch verwenden
kann. Drücke auf Stunden senden, dann erstellt
es mir eben die E-Mail mit den ganzen Daten im Betreff.
Die ich dann automatisch versenden kann.
In den Notizen sind die jetzt wieder alle gelöscht,
sodass ich.
Moment, habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Die verschicken CSV über Mail, verschicken die CSV
Dateien im E-Mail Betreff.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ist das ernsthaft?
Sagt mir, dass ich nicht recht habe.
CSV über den E-Mail über das E-Mail Subject.
Okay, das ist das ist ja mal richtig.
Pleading Edge Technologie 2022.
Nee.
Ich.
Glaube, ich glaube, die E-Mail ist dann für
sein Arbeitgeber, oder?
Mir aber die Anfangs Kilometer des Tages nicht merken
muss, habe ich mir eine Automation erstellen und zwar,
wenn Apple Carplay verbunden wird, da ich jedes Mal
andere Autos verwende und ich somit im Bluetooth nicht
genau das ein Auto auswählen kann, habe ich eben den
Weg über Carplay genommen und da kann man jetzt mal
reinschauen und zwar checkt mein Handy erst mal, ob ich
überhaupt arbeiten muss und wenn ich arbeiten muss,
fragt es mich, wie viele Kilometer mein Fahrzeug hat.
Ich verwende Carplay nämlich auch privat und will natürlich die Automation nur haben, wenn ich auch arbeiten bin.
Das Protokoll im Kalender finde ich schon mal ganz praktisch.
Den Zwischenstand der Variablen in der Reminders App ist ganz praktisch.
Hatten wir auch schon länger nicht, glaube ich.
Okay, alle Autos, mit denen du sie fährst, haben Carplay, wirft eher mehr Fragen auf als weniger, aber auf
jeden Fall ganz schön ausgefuchst, was du da gebaut hast in deinem Shortcut-Monster.
Wie das Ganze funktioniert, lasse ich euch jetzt mal schauen.
Ich werde euch jetzt in höherer Geschwindigkeit noch durchlaufen.
Ihr könnt ja anhalten, wenn euch etwas interessiert.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte dem ein oder anderen neue Inspirationen geben.
Five-Hat-Time, Alter, bis du das zusammengekriegt hast.
Siehst du, das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ich glaube, dass dieses ganze visuelle Programmieren einfach nur nie jetzt irgendwie Mainstream werden wird.
Weil ganz ehrlich, wer programmiert sowas versus Text-Editor aufmachen?
Und...
Programmieren, ja.
Also klar, ich meine, für den Fall ist es logisch, ist sinnvoll, aber es gibt ja...
Also, ne, auf dem Tablet und auf dem Handy.
Aber ich meine, es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, sowas ist die Zukunft fürs Programmieren.
Nee, nee, nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ciao.
Danke auf jeden Fall.
Ist ein ganz schönes Monster.
Dieses Ding wäre wahrscheinlich in einer anderen Programmiersprache zehn Zeilen oder so.
Ich würde gerne mal schreiben, wie gut so ein Shortcut-Monster für dich zu warten ist oder anzupassen.
Alter, was ein Riesending, ja.
Das ist ja schon was.
Ja, das ist wirklich was.
Durchläuft.
Joachim hat sein Open-Up-Hochbeet eingesendet.
Da schauen wir mal eben rein.
Ein Hochbeet.
Ich bin jetzt ja richtig früh dran mit Aussaat und Anpflanzen in meinen Hochbeeten.
Und im März ist auch alles sehr gut gewachsen.
Aber Anfang April war Schnee und Frost angesagt.
Und die Frage war, wie man sich da entsprechend drauf vorbereiten kann.
Und die Frage eins ist, in welcher Nacht wird es denn jetzt dann auch frieren?
Man könnte natürlich...
Verstehe ich.
Ja, okay.
Oder das in der Zeitung...
Na, Wetterbericht höre ich ja für Kackdubs.
Geht das in diesem Jahrtausend noch?
Wird noch ein Baum gefällt und da wird draufgedruckt, wie das...
Wenn wir jetzt mal toben, nehme ich Open-Up 3.0.
Also, du darfst Bäume nicht einfach fällen, wann du willst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es euch erzählt habe.
Wir haben auch einen Baum bei uns gefällt.
Das musste man anmelden.
Das durfte man nur in gewissen Zeiten machen.
Und dann kam der Hit.
Dann kam der Hit.
Also, wir haben den Baum fällen lassen bei uns im Garten.
Und...
Dann wurde der Baum...
Der Baum wurde Baum gefällt.
Alles korrekt mit Genehmigung und alles in der richtigen Zeit.
Und dann lag der eine Weile im Garten rum.
Und so einen Monat später kam dann jemand, der den Baum quasi klein gemacht hat und mitgenommen hat.
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben, was passiert ist.
An diesem Tag, wo der Typ da war und hat den Baum zerlegt, stand auf einmal jemand vom Ordnungsamt bei uns vor der Tür.
Und er hätte gemeint, Nachbarn hätten angerufen, wir würden illegal einen Baum fällen.
Da hat wirklich irgendein Typ am Fenster geguckt und hat gesagt,
Ha! Der Max!
Da!
Der macht da einen...
Der Baum ist...
Das darf der nicht!
Und hat beim Ordnungsamt angerufen.
Ernsthaft.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Der hat nichts besseres zu tun gehabt, als vom fucking Ordnungsamt anzurufen.
Na, zumindest...
Wir haben die Genehmigung gezeigt, haben gesagt, der Baum ist schon seit einem Monat gefällt.
Wir schneiden den jetzt halt einfach klein.
Ja.
Boah, die Leute, Alter.
Meine Güte, was die für Probleme haben.
Und das nehme ich natürlich dann auch für mein Smart-Hochbeet.
Ja.
Das ist klar.
Wetterbericht gucken ist doof.
In dem Fall Wetterbericht über eine API abrufen, wenn man sowas automatisieren will, viel besser.
Bei der Wettervorhersage nutze ich das Open Weather Binding.
Das bietet hunderte von Parametern.
Wenn es denn nachts frieren sollte, dann gibt es nochmal eine extra Push-Benachrichtigung, auch aufs Handy.
Weiß nicht, ob sich das blöd vorkam.
Ich habe die Hochbeete dann mit einem Wärmeschutz...
... mit einem Wärmeschutzvlies eingepackt und in der ersten Frostnacht hatte ich dann noch die Idee, ein Teelicht reinzustellen, was dann noch zusätzlich Wärme abgibt.
Echt, das Teelicht?
Ein Teelicht pro Hochbeet?
Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Ein bisschen optimistisch, oder?
Ja.
Oder sind das irgendwelche Hochleistungs-Teelichte?
Brutal, mega, massive Teelicht.
Die globale Erwärmung vorantreibt.
Die Frage war dann, wie messe ich denn den Erfolg dieser Maßnahme?
Das klappt, okay.
Der einfache Teil war, habe ich meinen U-Outdoor-Motion-Sensor abgebaut und ins Hochbeet gelegt.
Dieser Sensor meldet eben nicht nur Bewegung, sondern misst auch Beleuchtungsstärke und Temperatur.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist an Open Hub?
Es ist Java.
Mal im Überblick.
Auf jeden Fall stimmungsvoller als ohne Teelicht.
Das ist im Fall wahr, ja.
Und der Plieger zu beantworten, ob es funktioniert.
Bei dem Setup beachte man, wie sorgfältig der U-Motion-Sensor als Temperaturfühler thermisch entkoppelt wurde.
Ah, komisch.
Vom Hochbeetboden mit einer Milchtüte.
Es kam der Frost und der Effekt war ziemlich exakt null.
Im Hochbeet genauso kalt wie im Garten drumherum.
Den einzigen nachhaltigen Eindruck hat meine Konstruktion auf die Folie gemacht, die an der Stelle über der Kerze durchgeschmolzen ist.
Tja, kann nicht alles funktionieren.
Und ich habe die Messung einfach weiterlaufen lassen.
Und zu meiner Überraschung, am Nachmittag war die Temperatur unter der Folie im Hochbeet 40 Grad.
Dann hast du in das Hochbeet einen Eiswürfel gelegt?
Ventilator.
Nee, du willst es ja, dass es warm ist.
Ah, nee, über 29.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich das Hochbeet auf mein Handy gesendet.
Wie haben die das nur im Mittelalter gemacht?
Ich hoffe, dass die Pflanzen trotz aller meiner Bemühungen auch die nächsten Frosttage überstehen.
Und im Sommer werde ich euch dann zeigen, wie man es schafft, mit einer smarten Bewässerung und vier Wochen Urlaub das Hochbeet komplett eskalieren zu lassen.
Danke, Joachim.
Ich wollte dich nicht angreifen.
Ich finde es cool, so ein Experiment so zu machen.
Und ein Ergebnis des Experiments kann ja eben auch sein, dass es irgendwie in die Hose geht.
Ja, finde ich auch nicht schlimm.
Ich hoffe, dass die Pflanzen haben das alles überlebt und eskalieren.
Finde ich cool, dass er das einschickt, auch wenn es nicht geklappt hat.
Ja, mit der Einsendung.
Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall auf das Update.
Vielen Dank.
Dann hat Mike geschickt, dass seine Tür schließt, wenn die Klimaanlage einschaltet.
Wir haben kürzlich im Dachgeschoss, im Schlafzimmer eine Mitsubishi...
Ist das Text-to-Speech? Nee, oder?
... Klimaanlage einbauen lassen.
An dieser Stelle vielen Dank an...
Nee, kein Text-to-Speech.
... für den Tipp, diese mit Tado zu steuern aus deinem Video.
Denn die App von Mitsubishi ist wirklich nicht gerade ideal.
Ich habe auch eine Mitsubishi-Klimaanlage.
Und da habe ich ein ESP mit Infrarot-LED, wo man das ein- und ausschalten kann.
Gerne die Tür zum Schlafzimmer tagsüber auf, um auch unter anderem dem Saugroboter den Zugang zu gewähren und da mal durchzuschalten und zu wischen.
Aha.
Was aber kontrapolitisch...
... positiv ist, wenn abends die Klimaanlage dann vorklimatisieren soll und auch wenn wir noch nicht zu Hause sind, sich einschaltet, um den Raum runter zu kühlen im Sommer.
Ja, ja.
Deshalb habe ich nach einer Lösung gesucht, wie ich die Tür automatisiert schließen kann, sobald die Klimaanlage sich einschaltet.
Das ist eine...
Okay.
Ja, ja, ja, verstehe ich.
Ich bin in den Recherchen auf ein elektronisches Magnetschloss gekommen, über 12 Volt, der über Strom zu- und abfällt.
Ja, aber der Magnet ist doch im Leben nicht so stark, dass der die Tür von ganz auf zu zuziehen kann.
Und wenn, klatscht die Tür mal fest.
... entsprechend sich magnetisiert oder entmagnetisiert und so einen weiteren Magneten festhält.
Ich kann folgen.
Aber fällt die Tür dann wieder ins Schloss?
Ein entsprechendes 12-Volt-Netzteil habe ich dann mit einer Schaltsteckdose...
Ich check's nicht.
... verbunden über Home Assistant...
... ein...
Die Tür war doch komplett auf.
Wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Ist das so, dass die Tür automatisch schließt, wenn sie nicht gehalten wird?
So rum würde das nämlich mehr Sinn ergeben.
... eine Automatisierung programmiert, der bei Einschalten der Klimaanlage gemäß Zeitplan von TADO die Schaltsteckdose ausschaltet für 5 Sekunden.
Und somit lässt der Magnet die Tür los.
Und die Tür wird geschlossen.
Ich sehe da keinen Schließer oben an der Tür.
Seht ihr da was?
Die Schaltsteckdose ausschaltet für 5 Sekunden.
Und somit lässt der Magnet die Tür los.
Und die Tür wird geschlossen.
Wo?
Das da?
Also von was geht die Tür denn jetzt zu?
Ja, also wo ist die?
Ist hier eine Feder oder was ist das?
Die Schließung der Tür...
Hier hinten.
Ah, okay.
Hier hinten ist irgendwas.
Was ist dran?
Durch zwei Türschließer.
Ah, okay.
Einmal oben.
Einmal mit einem.
Ja, okay, okay, okay.
Er hat es erst versucht mit einem Türschließer zu lösen.
Allerdings scheint da die Kraft nicht auszureichen, um die Tür vom Magneten wegzuziehen.
Und jetzt, äh, mit schlechtem Timing kriegst du voll die Tür von...
Ja.
Deshalb habe ich da noch einen zweiten mit angebracht.
Mit dem Gesicht.
Auf der Tür.
Und jetzt ist die Kraft auf jeden Fall ausreichend, diesen, die Tür vom Magneten, der...
... der...
... entmagnetisiert ist, auch wegzuziehen und automatisch zu schließen.
Durch die Automatisierung schließt sich die Tür nun...
Das kann ich bei mir gar nicht machen.
Im Zweifelsfall ist die Katz da gerade dazwischen.
Und das Ding geht doch ordentlich zu, also...
... drei Raken, der Magnet ist automatisch wieder magnetisiert.
Nach fünf Sekunden und hält so...
Aber an sich ist die Idee cool.
... euch hier eine kleine Idee präsentieren und der eine oder andere findet sie gut und setzt sie vielleicht auch um.
Vielen Dank.
Auf jeden Fall eine ganz spannende Lösung, gerade im Zusammenspiel mit Saugrobotern und Heiz- oder in diesem Fall Kühlsituationen.
Auch hier wieder Home Assistant.
Das wird schon merklich mehr bei den Einsendungen.
Also, wie gesagt, wenn ihr Interesse habt und ihr wollt, dass dieser Kurs zustande kommt, Spiel und Zeug kommen.
Slash.
Ha.
Ja, waren ein paar coole Sachen dabei, muss man... muss man sagen.
Äh, nee.
Ich benutze meinen auch nicht mehr.
Ich habe ja zwei.
Einen ganz blöden, der einfach nur sinnlos im... äh, sinnlos... äh...
...sinnlos random fährt und einen Roborock S5 geflasht.
Benutze ich beide gerade nicht mehr.
Auch gut gegen Einbrecher. Du meinst, dass du den mit der Tür K.O haust.
Äh, muss das Ding aber schon ordentlich Schmackes drauf haben.
Warum ich den nicht...
Was kann der geflasht, der hat ein Webinterface und braucht nicht die China-Chinesen-Cloud-App.
Warum ich den nicht benutze?
Weil es besser und einfacher geht, einmal alle... keine Ahnung... zwei Wochen oder so.
Mal schnell mit dem großen Staubsauger durchzuflitzen.
Oder so.
Ich muss nicht oft saugen. Wozu?
Ich bin müde. Immer noch.
Dabei schon zwölf.
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Ich wohne ein bisschen außerhalb von...
Also ich wohne nicht direkt in Frankfurt, also nicht direkt in Hanau.
Ein bisschen nebendran, aber in Natur kann man das nicht nennen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon.
Jetzt muss ich aber erstmal was essen gleich.
So, eine Sache können wir uns noch angucken. Zeig mal her.
Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an? Das ist zu lang.
Das ist zu lang, zu lang.
What's a Homelab? Ne, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Dashboard. Ah, das gleiche Dashboard habe ich auch.
Docker UI, brauchen wir nicht.
Media Streaming, brauchen wir auch nicht.
Downloading, brauche ich doch keinen eigenen Container für.
Monitoring, Uptime Kuma habe ich auch am Start.
Storage und Backup, sowas habe ich nicht.
Backup habe ich aber, Storage mit Fotos habe ich nicht.
DNS Filter, Payol habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe Adblock Home.
Gut, Video geschaut, easy.
Jailbreak PS3, ja das gucken wir jetzt.
Ich habe nämlich noch eine PS3 mit ganz schön alter Firmware.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, warum ich die jailbraken sollte, aber ich meine, warum nicht, ja?
... Sony releases a new official firmware for the Playstation 3.
The wonderful folks over at PS3 Exploit come up with a new solution for us to get PS3 hand up and running.
I'm about to teach you how to install PS3 HEN on your own system.
PS, was? PS3 HEN?
... system, whether it be fat, slim or super slim.
Fire up your PS3 and your PC and grab a USB-C port for that 32.
We're about to add some special new powers to your favorite console.
Before you get started, make sure that your PS3 is connected either to the wired or wireless internet.
I'm using a PS3 Super Slim for this example.
Let's check some key settings.
Before moving forward, from the cross-media bar on your PS3, slide to the right to set it.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als, weil da gerade gefällt mir gerade ein,
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als sie die Xbox One angekündigt haben und gesagt haben,
die Konsole muss always on sein und wem das nicht gefällt, für die haben die ein anderes Produkt,
nämlich die Xbox 360, wo sie ernsthaft gesagt haben, fuck off, verwendet halt die alte Plattform,
wenn ihr nicht always on wollt.
Das war eines der bedümmsten Aussagen, die sie je marketingtechnisch da getroffen haben bei Microsoft.
Und die Xbox One war ja auch ziemlicher Reihenfall.
Und das Windows, äh, das Xbox One Interface war kacke.
Das PS3 Interface fand ich jetzt auch nicht sonderlich toll.
Heute ist später was geplant, jetzt geh ich erstmal mit, aber das ist gleich.
Okay, weiter.
Ja, weiter, weiter.
Äh, Nudel wahrscheinlich.
Oh, Mac-Adress-Leak, huiuiui, da wird's aber kritisch.
You'll need to access the ps3exploit.com site twice, once from your PC and once from your PS3.
I've got it linked for you in the video description.
By the way, das ist ein weiterer Grund dafür, warum die Switch bis heute offiziell keinen Browser hat.
Scroll down on the page until you see the listing in text format for the latest version of the hybrid firmware and click on it.
This takes you to the PSX Place website, which has a listing where you can download hybrid firmware...
Jetzt sind wir mal ernsthaft, diese Seite sieht nicht so aus, als will ich von da was runterladen und installieren.
Die sieht irgendwie ein bisschen shady aus.
Aber gut, diese ganzen Seiten mit Custom ROMs und Sachen, die sehen alle so aus.
...different mirrors.
Scroll down on the page until you see the listing for the links for the three mirrors that are available.
In this case I'm just going to use mirror number one, which is MediaFire.
Select the mirror of your choice and click on it.
And if you chose mirror number one for MediaFire, well, all you have to do is click the big download button to grab the hybrid firmware and download it to your computer.
Once you download the hybrid firmware zip file...
Achso, das ist das, was du nicht gebannt wirst mit der Mac.
Ja, okay, komm mal zum Punkt, Alter.
Ja.
Pup. Ein Pup-File.
Und es ist Windows 11.
EGIT.
Monk HS.
Windows 11.
Ja, Woodface, Alter.
Ja, auf, weiter jetzt. Gib Gas.
Ja, okay, okay, weiter.
Ja.
ob der pass
Gucken wir nicht wie ever notice des in fps games
Der läuft auf webkit
Ja ich habe letztens gelernt dass man linux fernseh receiver auch webkit installiert aus welchen gründen auch immer
Ihr work at subway auf so einen subway sandwich hätte ich echt mal wieder bock
Leider habe ich das letzte also es gibt immer weniger subways in deutschland die haben es irgendwie haben sie wie verkackt
Leider habe ich die letzten subway sandwiches nicht vertragen ich hatte da so heftigen
Ja ihr könnt ihr könnt euch vorstellen
Danach du tschüss dass ich da nicht mehr hin bin pipo pupu genau
Ne steak and cheese steak and cheese ist das beste
steak and cheese ist pock
subway verwirrt neue leute immer
Kennt ihr das wenn jemand noch nie im subway war und die fragen ihn dann so wie sieht es damit aus dass da und extra hier und
Da und hier und so und da und wie die leute sind immer voll verwirrt du musst in wirklichkeit eigentlich passt abweltlos sagen
1 satt des tages am besten mit gutschein
Ein satt des tages ohne extra ohne ohne ohne ohne
Brotsorte aussuchen fertig weil die leute denken dann das kostet nicht mehr
also auch
ja doppeltings könnte man nehme ja doppelt käse dabei haben sie gar keine ahnung dass der scheiß
unglaublich teuer wird wenn ich glaube wenn du wirklich ein subway sandwich machst und alles
doppelt drauf machen lassen da kostet das 20 euro oder so frischkäse hat auch also du hast ja du
hast ja was abwärts so frischkäse diesen diesen cheddar cheese dann hast du die scheiben und ich
habe oftmals tatsächlich letztes also letzte zeit wo ich dann aber sagt er frischkäse genommen die
belegen das wenigstens hier ordentlich jetzt wird es mal kurz frittiert das sind manche leute
bei subway kannst du dir das auch bestellen in so einem komischen rap und sowas das habe ich nie
verstanden warum man das macht und man kann sich sein subway was auch ganz wir ist man kann sich
den subway auch als deshalb auch als salat bestellen das verstehe ich auch nicht warum
man das machen sollte tuner
da bist du satt danach nach der tuner paste hier ist ein sap teurer als ein döner früher schon früher
hast du also mit also wenn du es clever gemacht hast nicht dann hast ein sap des tages hat früher
glaube ich fünf euro gekostet mit ohne ohne bonus ja also ich glaube fünf euro hat das immer gekostet
und mit gutschein teilweise noch günstiger
döner ist mittlerweile ähnlich also ich glaube mittlerweile ist gar kein so großer unterschied
ok das würde ich nicht machen tun fisch mit diesem case das habe ich immer nicht ja ja ganzes und
satt des tages kostet keine fünf euro also ich war ein fortlog wie man das nennt im bus subway
also die 30 cm großen sabs holt long weil kekona und so aber am besten was er mit gutschein hinzugehen
gehen. Ob man da auch
sein Prime-Sub einlösen kann?
Frag sie mal. Sag, du streamst
das dann auch.
Ah, Paprika wollte ich nie. Paprika ist
Pains-Champ.
Jalapenos, das muss sein.
What the fuck?
Ja, das ist das Problem, dass manchmal
der Kram dann so durchgeweicht ist,
wenn du so viel Kram drauf machst.
Naja, gut. So sieht's
bei Subway aus.
So, Leute. Ich geh jetzt was essen und heute Mittag
machen wir den EPG-Champ weiter.
Hapa-Hapa.
Pepo-Fett mach ich jetzt.
Ist irgendjemand, den man nochmal auf die Schnelle
hosten könnte? Zeig mal her.
By the way, Diablo Immortal soll
ein mega krasses Pay-to-Win sein. Also
im Prinzip nix anderes erwartet.
Label-Champ
ist nicht dead. Wir haben einfach zu viel Zeug zu tun.
Egal, Leute.
Ich hab mega Hunger. Ich geh was essen. Wir sehen uns
später. Bis dann. See you.